That fucking turtleneck and it just
blows up like a python with a fucking
sandwich and it's throat.
Hello.
Cause you're a disgusting like me.
Right? Rogun is in a different function.
Dusting to
guys discussed this guys must have a girl
like fucking you. And she reaches down
and touches your gut and you know,
it's just like squishy fucking wet flesh
and as there's no tone to it and like
listen, think of as you are fucking,
you have to be disgusted by this.
You're not do something on the chip.
You listen.
How do you not care who's touching you?
Fat.
I kill all my own boners
I can't get past how
disgusting it must be to fuck me to fuck.
I really do.
I I've,
but sex is not like a driving force
to make me do fucking squats and
no, no, no, no, no, no. Even if they got
it or they don't know. The point is like,
how do you not think about how
fucking gross deck you daddy did
you want your porn?
If you would turn the porn off,
you would admit it. Yes I would. I
would. I would a guy like, listen,
I fucked in the dark.
All right,
show coming up with muscles
or sunlight behind me.
That fucking movie. Go Fuck
you. So I come in real quick.
I'll bang it when you're asleep.
And I'm one of those guys
to keep your fucking belly. I fucking
the dark, but they'd feel a fucking,
we're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com and then it
got done with the plug.
Zelda.
We're one more makers of Alpha brain.
We have like actually have
a start thing here. Uh,
the cognitive enhancing supplement
that I'm giving a Doug, Stan hope,
Doug Stanhope,
this in your system right now will cure
you of the evil that is the mushrooms
because right now your mind
is taken over by an organism,
by an intelligent life form.
Thanks dude. Who gave me mushrooms?
I thought I completely dismissed
the guy at the merch booth.
I think it was giving me a
poster of something. He goes,
you want to open that later? And uh, I
go, I should check, get my merge bag,
which is scary. When I travel,
I have to scour my merge bag,
a bag of whatever it might be.
I thought it was a poster.
It was a rolled up giant envelope,
but it had mushrooms in it,
so I can't travel with them, so I don't
go low. I'm going to fucking either.
Usually I just give them away, but I
fucking, I haven't tripped in a year,
so he didn't go and I'm coming to the
Rogan podcast and you're on the Alpha
brain. I don't even, yeah, Alpha brain.
I might, let's smoke some pot too.
I don't even really that awesome. Later,
later, it'll really fuck this fucking,
I don't know. Might be
good. I have a show tonight.
Let's those washrooms
and put you on a different fucking
the do. Do. Do you understand?
You're going to go back to
Worcester to the ACLU. Aclu.
That's how deep this is going to fake it.
Are you familiar with what new nootropics
are you ever tried any things? No. No.
I was like basically the loop.
Joe, let's get you in the loop.
Duck Stanhope let's get Shannon a little
ducks. Stand up. You need a podcast?
My friends telling me to. Oh, you should
shop at the Co op instead of Safeway.
That's the fucking, yeah.
Oh, the Co op hip. No,
I live in a fucking small town. It's
called me and people. They don't,
they're not in the loop. They're
not in the Internet. Well, no.
What's there on the Internet?
It's a global world.
Doesn't need a fucking Internet.
It's just done a 6,000 people.
They yell out the window. Well, that's
what you really are. The Internet,
because you're in a town of 6,000 people.
You need to be connected with
everything else each other. Well,
that's all good too.
But I mean,
just for sanity's sake and to
keep in the fucking loop. Yeah.
Well we'll give you some of these,
what's it called?
Alpha brain.
Brain cognitive enhancing our supplement.
We also have new mood.
That is a five HTP Sarah time.
I took a three capsules of 0.3 2.4
milligrams of mushrooms on the trip here,
which was at one 30 who
knows how much is it? Well,
you know when you eat a mushroom,
how much of it is like cellulose put
them in capsules. That's what I'm saying.
So let's just cap had a capsule.
So yeah,
you might like to see me a fucking
instruction. That's why I was, oh,
he did a [inaudible].
It's like a grant per capsule.
If you really look at,
the guy gave me like instructions
on the fucking, well,
we hope that the Alpha brain doesn't
set off. The fuck point is here.
We wanted to send out my own plug.
Thanks guy. Who I completely dismissed.
He looked like so you know,
I have no idea.
I thought it was giving me
a poster as the universe.
He's just an agent by
the way of the universe.
Some guy that fucking tried
to barge into the green room,
Brian with a tee shirt even.
I won't, I won't plug him.
Go to fucking Joe rogan.net. Click on
the link, entering the code name, Rogan,
and get 10% off your
Alpha brain supplements.
That was one of the best commercials we
ever did. Folks. I know you don't like
commercialization gentleman,
but it's a fucking free podcast.
I know.
They're ridiculous.
The ridiculous.
They need to be edited.
This is a good argument for the
unnecessary having a producer.
All right, I need a real producer.
Yeah, it was fun. She goes,
fun arguments was a fun.
What did you know the difference between
that and that's the fuck you just hit a
button and now we're actually talking.
Now it actually is the talking.
I no longer have to promote anything,
but in the beginning,
before we start the way,
the way we got it out of the way,
we used to just talk about the flashlight
all the time and then we figured out
once along,
somewhere along the line,
it's best to just get it out of the
way and then go about the podcast.
So that's the, even if it seems a
little disingenuous, but I am just,
it's a vehicle. I'm bit scatterbrained.
Doug, Stan hope on his way over here.
My good buddy. Dunked Stan Hope. Well,
I've not seen in probably like a year,
a year, somewhere around there.
Yeah, no, it's, it's been a while.
Maybe a year and a half since the last
time I did the show. Yeah, man. Yeah.
Yeah. And when, when let's see your live
show, dude. I learned something I learned.
I don't like going to shows
where I have to stand up. Oh,
that was a couple of years ago. That
was, was it fucking Kit Kat club? Yeah.
That's like you make years ago. Do
you have people sitting down and, no,
I'm doing it now that I can cut my own
deal. I'm fucking dead back at the Improv.
Oh, that's nice. Oh, so
they just, they gave up.
They came around.
I can do an off night.
What's going on with Joey's
microphone, Bro? Oh Mike, I need,
I need fucking buck a lot. They got
all these open mic as Tuesday too.
It's Doug fucking standup.
It's all over.
You've got all these fucking books during
the week. Bring it this fucking savage.
But I can do one night. They're on an
off night and bring my own fucking crowd.
You were one of the first guys who figured
out how to get your own crowd online.
You know,
you,
what you did was really a smart move
by just leaving the comedy clubs almost
completely and just going a little rock
and roll clubs and booking it yourself.
And yeah, it was all out
of spite. Spite does,
it drives me a lot. Well, you
really drive, but it was genius.
It was ballsy needing to
fuck these motherfuckers know
you're a voice and you've
got to get the fuck out.
I don't give a fuck what you do.
You don't want to hire me.
I got to keep doing what I do.
It's the best way that you did
it. The best way though. You, you,
you really found your own audience.
Like you're one of those dudes where
you'd go to see a standup show, you know,
it's a fucking Stan help crowd. We see
him walking down the street, you know,
they're all days from suicide.
They're all small kid.
I was in Calgary where I actually crossed
this. I, I'm looking for the GIG. Oh,
that's right. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah,
we talked about this last time.
Wait, Calgary, there's a train
station in front of where the Gig was.
So I see all these fucking
who'd loans standing.
I think that waiting for a train.
So I crossed the street to get away from
them and then only to realize that was
they were waiting not for the train,
but that was my gig.
That was the fucking queue for my fucking
show that I'm crossing the street to
get away from my own fans
cause they seem scary.
That's one of his fans right there.
Look at we're to stand
hosts fans right there.
That's how he shows up with the outfit.
Not Making me look at fucking is
it dude that's on fear factor.
This new season of fear factor.
And there was a thing on CNN, uh,
about uh [inaudible] you
are saying, oh yeah, if I,
if they did fear factor,
I'd suck the Devil's Dick again.
And then now I'm fucking watching football
and here is [inaudible] he was back
out Rogan's big fucking huge
head and my face, I'm 55 inches.
A fear factor. I love it though.
They came with the long money,
Stan hope they came
with that patient home.
Cash in the middle of the
fucking world falling apart.
We're way too old for fucking talk about
selling out or all that shit that young
comics care
about rivalries. Dane Cook. Hey Dane Cook.
Thank you very much Dane Cook lay.
I'm doing this fucking benefit show
in Tucson that it's a long story,
but they, Dane Cook's that, hey, I haven't
done standup, but I'll help you out.
Like fuck thanks. Thanks a
lot. Lee. Who gives a shit?
Someone emailed me today about men.
See It is new Med z thing is homey.
So hot around and touches on your bit.
Like who gives a fuck fucking
internet snipes doing the benefit.
No, he's not. He hasn't done
standup and almost a year
I don't have a clue where I ran
into him at the premiere warriors,
not to name drop. It's on the red
carpet. Avoid the Paparazzi Dang visible.
Like snipey about that. Like yeah.
DANCO well he didn't put the like, uh,
I don't know how Twitter really works,
but he said he didn't put the
apostrophe thing in front of it.
So he's just telling you your own
fans that he's promoting. Like why?
Oh, I see. I see. I don't know how
Twitter works. Yeah, he didn't put the a,
the apple are just still
sell fucking country.
They're very comfortable old people.
Well,
people are looking for a reasonably
content because they're trying to distract
themselves from a shit
life that they live.
Instead of looking at their life and
trying to fucking figure out their real
problems.
They just go online and just fucking
don't give a fuck a comedy anymore.
Do you? I care about good colony.
I still live, but I still enjoy it.
I realized somewhere along the line it's
mostly just jealousy and insecurity.
And you know,
one of the realize,
one of the things I realized is that
people have shit way of looking at comedy.
When I used to tell people that I'd take
Joey on the road with me, I take people,
you know, like, uh, like
who'd you do rascals with?
Oh, Joey Diaz and I, he goes,
you bring fucking Joey Diaz on the road.
Like, what are you crazy like you, you,
you follow Joey Diaz on purpose. And I
was like, and I couldn't understand it.
I was like, why would you even think
like that? Like why does everybody,
everybody's worried at every moment
that they're not the life of the fucking
party. Like at every moment they can't
even enjoy when other people are funny.
I'm like, you don't want to be around
funny people. That's all I want to do.
I want guys to fucking crush in front
of me. You know, I want, I want to just,
I want the whole thing to be fun.
I don't want to just be the only
one who's having fun up there.
Spoiled socially because yeah,
my fucking best friends in the world.
Literally the funniest people alive.
So spoiled. So if you try to hang out
with the idiots, go to your fucking,
the in laws are so shit udo
when they tell you you could do this
joke on stage, they don't understand.
They don't see if feel like
it, you know, when I was,
I was dating this girl one time,
she's a nice girl,
but I was at a transitionary point in
my life. There's nothing bad about her.
She was just who she was. Was young
girl, want to do what you want to do.
She was always upset. She was, she's a
good girl. She was a really good person.
But she was always upset that I was
doing other things and I was hanging out
this pool hall all the time and she
would always give me shit about it.
But you know,
I finally,
I had to have a sit her down and have
a moment like I have fucking fun.
You don't understand. Again, I have
to remind people I'm tripping a bit.
Just picturing you at a pool hall is a
flashback in a movie and weird hair on
a full head of it.
Back to Joe Rogan and pool hall days back.
No, it wasn't in Boston. It was New York.
I became obsessed when I first moved to
New York, but, uh, she, she hated it.
She fucking hated it because I never
wanted to hang out with her and I would
tell her, look, you know,
and I had a conversation with
him like, look, you're a,
you're a very cool person.
You're very sweet. I don't,
I don't want to date another girl,
but I don't want to fucking hang out
with you every day. Well you hate chicks,
that's all. Hey checks.
I hate dumb ones though.
I hate dumb dudes and I hate dumb
checks equally, it's not a gender thing,
it's just dummies. But when you're in that
situation, man, when you're just like,
God, I just can't, I can't hang out with
you all the time. It's, it hurts me.
It hurts me to know that there's
all this fun going on over there.
I'm hanging out with you and these dudes
are gambling is staying up to three in
the morning and no one's married.
No one knows what the fuck
is going on the next day,
they're all wild gambling motherfuckers
and they're my friends and they're funny
and they say funny shit and I'm like,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to hang out with you
and what are you going to tell me?
Like what movies you like? Well, you
didn't tell me what you like to eat.
You know what your mom said. That was
mean. You know, she's just fucking Christ.
I want to go have fun. Yeah, no,
I think go ahead. Are you to
foreground? I hate to fucking, I'm talk.
No, no, I'm good. I'm good. I was
just hit a roadblock. Cramping.
My mind is so important to have friends
that are fun. You know, it's the, the,
the one thing that you, you know, you get
out of the podcasts and shit too though.
These like people that don't know anybody,
like you don't know anybody like Joey,
they get to talk to you
essentially on a podcast.
They get to kind of feel your vibe,
see how you think about things.
When you sit down and see somebody talk
for an hour, you don't just see him talk.
You see how they think and you
see how they decipher stuff.
And it kind of can give you insight on
how maybe you're not doing it that way.
Or maybe you could, you could do it
that way and it would enhance your shit,
you know? Right. It's so important, man.
You can get stuck in a fucking bad place
with bad friends. Are you freaking out?
No,
not freaking out.
I'm just enjoying the entire
experience led Zeppelin's on the wall.
We've got this new studio for the folks
who are just listening on iTunes. If you,
uh, go to Ustream. Dot.
TV Ford Slash Joe Rogan,
you could watch all these now and uh,
we actually have it set up where
we have fucking TV on delay.
Yeah. Weird. Huh? I should not look
in that direction. I did that for you,
so you can,
you know,
it'd be one of my favorite stat hopes
stories that I tell is when you and I did
mushrooms and then we,
uh,
went out to the desert and it was the
day the war started watching pregame for
the war. I'll never,
I'll never forget this.
You and I were sitting in young Urban's
living room, twisted to our balls, right?
And they had a fucking giant
kettle of some kind of Iowasca.
They were trying to produce this,
how many of them as scary and it give
us just a weird feeling and ahead.
It didn't get us off
at all. Nothing. And I
had like,
I felt like a pop or like I like,
but I'll tell you what I bag of mushrooms
in my pocket and then I'd come in and
they have this whole fucking giant
kettle going but the two of them together
though, I think that's what really
blasted it off. And you know,
that's what they think Soma
was. They think some of them
might've been, you know,
Soma for my ancient Hindu religion,
they don't know what it is.
But it was like the basis of a lot of
their belief in a lot of their, their,
you know,
their,
their ancient scriptures talk about it
and like grieve about Soma and they think
that it was,
am Anita miscarry and mushrooms mixed
with cubensis mushrooms like mixed like
that. And that might have been because we
were, we were fucking Alasta rude dude.
We,
I was,
I remember staring at the wall and
looking at this crazy geometric pattern of
the universe was made out of and
staying home, watching to the war.
It's like fucking, but
you go, this is what you,
you were standing there and you go,
holy shit is fucking, what's his name?
Frank Kelly Endo.
Do it and deploying it in picks as
I give you my pigs as John Madden who
hasn't been relevant for fucking seven
years.
We're sitting there blasted,
and I'll never forget this
because you just go, Holy Shit,
there's a fucking kick off
kickoff to the kickoff.
And we were, we were both like
really just starting a trip,
like it was just coming on
and then you go, Holy Shit,
there's a kickoff at six and we were
sitting, we just sat down at 45 we,
you get a cocktail of snacks.
We sat down, we were like,
Terry Bradshaw is going to fucking
come on and tell you how he feels.
It's like it's the strangest
time ever to be alive.
What kind of a world is this telling us?
The war coverage begins at five.
What are you saying? They timed it.
You told me they timed it. They waited.
Isn't it like a different time over there?
So they waited all day and it's not
like it was their time, but yeah,
it was primetime here.
Six in the afternoon to imagine if they
actually timed the missiles to prime
time in America. Probably had finally
fucking date. Probably fucking
fucking fucking advertisers.
God.
Well you know George Bush if uh,
yeah, three, three in the morning,
you know their time. Yeah. Sizzler.
We can get fucking tied to sponsor
it. If you're going to, you know,
new commit six who was such
a strange fucking moment man.
What a weird moment. Stand hope. Remember
those two broads? I live next to you
with a tall German chick that was
lanky and Q and a short Brunette.
And then there was the, the Chubby
at CIC, sage member. The cello.
Oh those are the,
yeah.
You did like heroin or something with
them or something off. I did everything.
I stopped.
I stopped the sages.
The one I did like sage's father,
I one time was the rolling stones'
manager.
And what he did for this chick was he
bought her a fucking blockbuster and
Ventura blockbuster. And she said, I don't
want to block. Turned her on to heroin.
And she was herpes herpes.
I didn't give him no fucking hurt because
she was giving me shit about having,
but she's over there and fucking Oh,
heroin with Joey Diaz to me,
I was homeless.
So she would come to the store on Sundays.
She would come to the store on Sundays
and give me pills and she would,
she was an expert in mixing. What was
that shit? That was big year MDB a
acts to see what white water she drinking,
none of that other stuff. Oh, Ghp.
And she bring it to the comedy store
and I'd be hosting on Sundays and she'd
give me drinks of the GSP,
whatever the fuck.
So this happened,
this one off for six months,
she'd take HB and Sundays
I go to a house broken,
like go to a house on Sundays
after I'd host, she come down,
we buy coke from chewy. We'd go to
Ralph's, we do heroin, eat her ass pills.
She has to fake little
shows that lingerie for me.
She was a hundred pounds overweight,
but this bitch ass, he want to eat. No,
no,
I didn't see it for a long time.
Right.
Then she started coming
around to Calistoga,
Tsp and so one fuck Liz is a great story.
I just got him up cause I was thinking
about staying hope on the way up here.
And uh,
our friend Mike was selling weed,
but then one time he worked
at CAA and he goes, listen,
one of the interns older than me blew up.
He ended up being Whitney
Houston's manager and you know,
and the tour manager and
he's looking for powder.
So everyday they would come over and
I would sell Bobby Brown and Whitney
Houston, you know, they would come over
like $1,100, which was pretty diem money.
I was taking Whitney's per diem money,
right?
Every day they come out with a little
white envelope and give me the per diem
money and I go up to the Martell
cartel and I'd buy 14 grams of Blo.
Take an eight ball out and cut it and
then give it to Whitney Houston and they
were fucking going crazy. They,
this went on for 30 40 days,
but I couldn't snort all the blog was,
I couldn't store it.
It was just too much. So I was giving
it to Maldon Martinez, the whole,
she's dead.
That's the coke that killed her.
So
I got,
I got like two ounces of block plus I
snorted all this coke and I can't smell it
no more. I called him back. I go mountain,
bring the club down to the fucking store.
Right.
I'm selling coke to Whitney fucking dad
picking me up at nine in the morning,
paging me on the Red Pager. I'm coming
downstairs, getting in the car with them,
going to the Martell cocktail to the
brothers going in the house with two grams
of coke already cut my pocket.
And I would just go and take rocks out,
throw the cut and mix it up and
give it right back to them, the car,
and they'd be happy as shit.
They were invited me to a and m records
to come party with them. I don't party.
I was selling them.
I was getting him a half ounce and
taking an eight ball out and throwing an
eight ball to cut it. What does an
eight ball? Three and a half grams.
I haven't done coke my entire fucking
life and I don't know like a percentage,
like what it cost. Percentages
are. Isn't that crazy
sleazy that it's all cut
though with a fucking shit like
coke because someone goes, Hey,
do you want to do a
bump? And you go, okay,
but you don't know what he's never bought.
When you go out with Stan,
hope somebody got cokes, he'll do
coke. You got an elephant tranquilizer.
Stan hopes like to go. We don't give
a fuck. The train's already running.
I got nowhere to be tomorrow. Fuck it.
We're here. We're ready. You know what?
I got here and he said he had mushrooms.
I'm like, what the fuck you don't.
You should.
This is the cock sucker and knocks on
your door with rolling papers and no weed.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I've got no rule like rolling papers.
Next time you bring those fucking
mushrooms with you and we could have been
right here on this would have been a
great fucking podcast not to listen.
So I'm Robyn Whitney and Bobby
Brown for a fucking month.
I'm robbing that blow every day. I
can't do it. I can't snort it fast.
How much are they doing?
They're doing a half ounce a day.
This is why this is not
this. No, this is not da.
They're doing a half ounce a day, which
is three ounces a week. Oh my God.
And singing. What does that look
like? Whoa. Announces like this,
like a half ounce of weed.
Like God, they're doing,
they're doing one of those a day.
Got Bobby Brown, his face twisted,
and I was getting the shit that
was flaky. So my gosh, right?
I tell Marilyn and bring the
would, well, aren't they?
Aren't they feeding and entourage
at this point about coke?
It's just those two. Oh, there's only so
much coke left. All right, you gotta go.
You gotta go. You gotta go. Right?
So this went on so and salary and they
called Maryland Martinez. I go, Maryland.
Do me a favor,
bring the blow to the comedy store
cause I'm just going to sell it.
And a kid after my set gives me a little
Baggie with the bottom of it filled up
like not even, not even two lines. And I
put it in my pocket and I take it home.
When I get home I do it. It's not
coke, it's crank. So I'm on fire now.
It's three in the morning.
I'm in my house on fire.
I got the coke kid who hasn't
stopped shaking since. All right.
I have the coke and the fucking
car. No, I'm not. I'm not bouncing.
I have the coat in the car.
I always do that shit.
I have the coat in the car right.
And I wouldn't bring it upstairs.
I don't like coke in my house.
So I would go down and do a little
bump by five in the morning.
You would always keep it in the car
and the car ride height. I don't like,
I don't like him.
I don't want to be parents,
but I don't like it in my house anyway.
I never like coconut. It's just bad.
I don't like it.
I used to leave it outside on the rocks
and somebody else's garage and then I'm
would go in and do a bump
and go back upstairs.
So there's one night I got upstairs and
the pages going off and it's sage and I
said fuck it. Let me just
bring the two ounces to our
house, a blow. And I brought,
at that time it was like an ounce
and a half and three quarters.
This bitch picked me up at six in the
morning with a case of Starbuck coffee in
Canada,
half a gallon of vodka.
And we went back to the house and we
did that whole package of blo heroin,
Valliant and BMA a GSP.
We did how many days? How
many days? Whole days.
One day afternoon I had to
get Scott Wolfe, Josh moves,
brother Frey though to come get me
over by the directors guild. Oh my God.
Two days I puked till Thursday.
Jesus Christ is how sick I was.
The fucking Houston's kept calling me
and I'm like, fuck you motherfuckers.
I'm out of commission. Right. So
finally that next week was the grammys.
This is the last time I seen them.
I don't think I told you about this
last time ever. I seen Whitney Houston.
I got a call on a Monday morning after
the grammys at nine in the morning and
they're like, it's your boy up.
He would have to be come get me,
and they pull up to my fucking house
where I live by the YMCAs and it was the
manager,
Whitney Houston and Ricky Martin in
the fucking back and they're all gone.
They're gone from the Grammy's that jaw,
all of them. Jaws are fucking going.
Jack and I got in the car with them.
I drive for the Martell caught
tell him sitting there like, oh,
I don't even know what drinking,
and I just looked out the window.
I was more paranoid than he
was. I got in, bought it,
brought it back to the college. That's
the last time I fucking said, wow. She,
they went out of town after that. They
were here to sing. They were doing,
this had to be 98 97 99 they would go
with the soundtrack to this James Bond.
I Wyclef Jean who just robbed half
a fucking Haiti. That cock sucker.
That's why I'm 80 you didn't see that
he robbed his own fucking earthquake
relief. Fun? No, that
million dollar. Yeah, Bro.
That's why I don't send it unless I
see the guy on the street bleeding.
I give them money.
When you send $100 they get 30 of it.
Did you steal my change jar in
the late nineties probably did.
Fucking change jar.
What's a change jar by the
head changing bluejeans.
Talking about Robert.
Yeah.
He was just thinking about the nineties
where we lived on curse on it and there
was a fucking change. Our
Ego. That probably is fucking,
I called you Joey jingles for awhile.
No, no. I would never write change.
Rob something.
No,
it was someone who just fucking
calling a fucking cup of cheese. Yeah.
It was just a weird thought.
I smoked pot, which I never do. The fuck
is wrong with you. I'm a professional.
Yeah. Now I remember calling in Seattle.
What time? I was opening up for a stay
at home and I picked them up in an Rv.
It was snowing in Seattle.
Help. Weird chick copy Carol,
who I stuck the fucking a little bit
before Perez. He was around for that.
He knew all about that
shit. Seattle. He Brian,
you shouldn't probably played copyrighted
shit on the background like this. No,
I'm not just playing old shit.
All right with that,
I'm looking at all these images. Probably
not fucking start defamation suits.
That's a definition.
It's Reiki.
Fucking Martin waters is a
two story would definitely,
if it didn't fucking happen,
they wouldn't give it up.
You Martin clean and sober now he
came out of the closet, has got kids.
So he'll look these opinions and stories
and not a representative of the Joe
Rogan and all that.
What the fuck is,
I was actually promoting copyrighted
stuff and what is the [inaudible] on this
story might think that you,
the vigils date,
the bucket on this story's
going to get on the Internet.
Years ago wasn't, he wasn't
going to say to me, no,
you remember be bitch the
fuck sing bitch St lets us,
I kept her alive for three fucking months
given all those rob Tam rocks and shit.
So you think it was just them
doing that amount? Joe Rogan,
if you could go crazy,
you got a check that's sucking your
dick ain't got no experience with this.
Fuck you want, I don't, I don't have
any experience. We have a fucking shame.
Jesus Christ.
No, no, no. I just noticed the fucking,
all the change had been taken out
and nothing else was stolen. I go,
who would do that? And I go,
I think Joey's back on drugs.
Maybe you fucking psycho. Oh, it's
impossible. Joey. You might've done it.
Forgot about it.
I think the last time I went to stay
in hope sound like I had an open house
policy. He had an open house policy.
Still do. Like who would just like,
I was just going, this is the fucking
like 1996 we were all broke. I'm going,
which one of my friends would
be broken off to just fucking,
I ever thought of you.
I was at the coach and horses dangles out
of my fucking mind and I couldn't walk
to uh, Vista. So I went to standalone
was cause he had the open door policy.
And I go to stay in hopes, I hope with
go. He's got the bunk beds. I get no,
this time it was the living room.
He just had a cut.
I get out of the car cause I couldn't
even make it to the fucking bed.
That's like there's an earthquake and I
wake up to the house and they opened my
eyes sideways and I see the clock.
So I'm focusing on the clock,
but the fucking earth is moving, you
know what I'm saying? And that was just,
that's I think the last time I was.
Do you still have that apartment?
It's subsidized. You have
somebody's rent control I to fuck.
I still live there all the time.
I still beat the horn when
I go by like a motherfucker.
I respect that Hennigan's there
now town. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you ever Miss La? Yeah. Now. Yeah.
Right now the fucking drive here
was horrific. I was going to change.
I was trying to get ahold of you.
If we have to do this the next
day I'm going to change my flight.
I'm like I can just fly.
I can fucking 10 days off.
I'll just fly of fucking somewhere.
I never do that.
Just fly somewhere for a vacation.
I had my passport in Costa Rica.
If I'm going to extend my stay
here to fucking hang out with you,
I'll probably be fucked up when I leave.
Why not?
And then just the thought of lax
fucking ruined that entire fantasy.
Really? Oh, sorry. He's going to talk
down here. No, it was perfect. All right.
That's fine. Well, my audio
functions are way fucked.
Oh yeah. Um, medicinally.
You know what I'm,
why did you move there in the first place?
Why did you decide to,
you live in Bisbee Arizona in the
middle of nowhere, right? What was the,
just wanted to get away and Paul's by ice,
the place I've found when I was driving
on the road, I really impulse buy. Yeah.
I don't even see the inside. Did you
know anything about the town pictures?
Did you know anything about the
town? I had been there a lot. Sorry.
I had a fucking, it's
fine dude. Yeah, yeah. No.
Alright dude. Dude, dude, dude, dude.
[inaudible] so, um, yeah.
So what's the downside?
What's the downside of living
in a tiny little town like that?
Cause you're in like a town of like what?
6,000 people or something crazy. Yeah.
Jake Lamata has come over to that house
a couple times. Jake Lamata the fighter.
Yeah. Really? Yeah. The Guy who they
made the movie regionally bull about.
What's that guy like? Uh, you know what?
I could do a fucking 20 minute bit.
That's the downside. Like he,
he lives there. Yeah. Yeah. No,
but you have to be respectful
of people there because
any good story that comes out of there,
of course your neighbor.
That's the downside to
living in a small team. Yeah.
You can't talk about half the fucking
stop sign because they cut you off.
Cause that guy will be behind you
in line it fucking Safeway. Yeah.
Like how often you run in the same
people over and over again. All the time.
All the time. Yeah. That's a
weird thing, huh? I go, yeah.
You get a fucking really funny
fucking bit about your neighbor.
So do you guys think that Joey is take
care of this change real quick? No,
I don't think she didn't see there's this
spot. Here's a spot on the microphone.
If I was,
it doesn't matter.
I was looking for it like I was to your
voice on where do you want not to me.
Not to you really? It sounded fucked. I
think it's probably those headphones. No,
no. Yeah, no. It's because of
my senses are peaked. Right?
So what's the good side?
There's gotta be a good side.
You know, I fucking love it.
One of the bad sides is I eat the road
now because I want to be home. Really?
And now you have a lot of
friends fucking joy in Cleveland.
Like what am I going to accomplish
that I haven't in 21 years? Same thing.
I'm going to fuck bro.
Soft cock at a younger girl all
night until she's diluted enough.
What are we going to do
with fucking triple run?
Let's do a triple run old
school. Take red band. The drive.
I'd fucking love to do that.
We did our 10 year anniversary.
Yeah. Becker and I, when
we did, you know, 10 years
from now we're going to go back and we
were going to do a Tribble run triple
runs are these legendary one
nighters in the northwest.
I forget where on radio we should
probably eat fucking entertain or some no,
this isn't attaining. Oh yeah,
yeah. But uh, uh, so you'd go,
you'd play Idaho falls.
That's where I met Joey Coco Diaz
Dribble Gig. I was in boulder,
Colorado was a host at the boulder broker,
the joker broker,
the joker broker and he came out on a
Tuesday and the ride driver's license for
a long time because I would live
down the road. I didn't have a home,
was the fucking joker brokers
address in Boulder, Colorado.
I got a Colorado license,
Kessler, Mike Kessler's house.
You bought the car from my Kessler. Oh,
that's right. Piece of shit. That's right.
You bought, yeah. That fucking dodge
neon forever. Jay Morph fucking,
yeah. Spotted me in the, uh,
parking lot of the comedy store in the
late nineties and said, ah, dodge neon.
Yeah.
He had some condescending thing where
I'm good for the environment or so what a
cunt that guy is. But we met Olga.
Broker run was Tuesday in boulder,
then you had Wednesday off and
then you had Thursday in Craig,
Colorado Friday and uh,
some other Gunnison and it ended up in
Colorado Springs at some fucking bond.
So Tuesdays you had to come to boulder
and I became friends with Doug and then
Wednesday you had off. So it was
going to happen with stay at a hotel.
He stayed at my house. That's when my
wife and I first broke up was a Congo.
That's when I first met him.
He was still telemarketing in
Vegas the second time he came back,
it just done evening at the Improv.
Yeah. Yeah. And you stayed again.
And that's how we became friends.
I didn't see him again.
He Won San Francisco and he came
up to Seattle and then I thought,
well it's fun when you go on one of
those gigs and you meet a real comic,
you know, cause he, you never know what
Joey, Joey came into the joker broker.
He was like the house,
but he didn't give a fuck.
You're like, hi, I'm the comic, and
he's like, I know, and he goes on stage.
I just had the fucking push
me pull you like that's it.
That's how I remember he was doing a bit
about having the shits and the vomits
at the same time, but you
knew it was honest because
you can tell by Joey's face.
He was fucking sick person.
He was like sweating profusely and it
was about having the push me pull you
shit, trying to figure out which
end to aim towards the toilet.
I got $50 a show and I would pull you,
I would take a hundred valiums and sell
them all for $3 a piece and I would make
$50 a show on a steak.
It was steak tonight and I had to go up
every Tuesday for the same 80 people and
do new material every fucking Tuesday,
so I'd have to get the bolt of paper
and write five minutes and no place to
practice. I didn't know about
that. I thought you just
wrote it and brought it up.
They're like, you know,
and it was the same people.
And I remember that if you got them
to lift their head up while they were
cutting into the state, that they
just paid six 95 four, you know,
those type of people.
That was their thing on Tuesdays
to comics and the state for $14
or whatever the fuck it was.
You know. But it's amazing how,
that's how I got into comedy.
If you could get them to look at you,
you did your job and get a
Gig once from Mike Clark,
Clark's brother Mike Clark is a great guy.
Lenny Clarke is one of
the legendary comedians of
Boston, a fucking awesome guy.
And Mike used to book me on a lot of
road gigs back in the Boston days and one
of them, he booked me. It was
the waiting room of a restaurant.
So it was as your people
are waiting to be seated,
they have like a room
where they all sit down.
I don't know why they didn't just make
that part a part of the restaurant too.
It was real weird. But they had a
band and then they had a comedian.
So these people are just sitting around
waiting and you can just go up and start
talking about blowjobs and taking shits
or whatever stupid act I had at the
time. And as I'm talking like
I'm in the middle of a bit,
right about the hit the punchline and
over the PA system that I'm using,
it's like Johnson Party of
two, your table's ready,
please come to the front desk.
And I'm like, oh no. It
was the same sound system.
So every time when you were on stage you
could be in the middle of talking and
they would just start announcing people's
names and it would happen like every
15 seconds. It was the most
ridiculous Gig of all time.
And I replaced a host that was a magician
that came out with a bird on stage,
but the bird will, we get stuck on
the lights and he would shit on.
So they had a fire him. That's
who I replaced. That's how my,
that's how my comedy career
and I'll never forget when I seen the
parrot or whatever, it was shit on him.
I went right to the manager on my dog.
Cause you've got the hosting
job was the winner of the,
of the Beck's comedy
competition. Beck's beer. Right.
And that's how I want the more popular
than that brand of beer right now.
What happened there? Beer. How can that
be? We're never caught on, I still,
I still drink Becks. Yeah. Some stanky
to it backs. It was like a little,
if they're out of Heineken you'll get it
back out again. Yeah, I'll take it. But
you just make it tastes like Heineken.
Remember honey brown.
It was really popular and like the like
nine early nineties you were a kid.
What do you think sells more bex
or Heineken. Heineken. Right.
I think it got commercials running.
Is that what it is? I guess so.
That's got a lot of commercials do.
I haven't seen banks.
I've been out of bex in forever.
Maybe I'm just prejudice.
Maybe I need to drop the bags.
Go get me a bag.
You are pretty prejudice with beer though.
I've noticed just from being in
comedy clubs, you're always like,
what the fuck is that? Why
aren't you drinking that?
You've got to get man's beer.
Like Sam Adams just started drinking
those little light fairy drinks. I'm like,
that's not really a beer.
Goddammit.
I tried to give me a fucking light
beer outta here, bitch. No light beer,
Sam Adams
beer that I like his ass.
Fuck yes.
They light up a mass.
Stella's and uh,
saint man,
Yo, we're going to handle the mass. And
it was at the club night grilled 93.
Oh yeah.
And then so there's three at that time I
hadn't followed Joey d. No, no,
no. It is on fire. There's a,
there's always nobody
with a mullet. Oh, please.
And he went up on stage in the middle of
his set as a priest walked by and stand
hopes. He's in my little corner of
his eye and he goes, hey father,
where are you going?
I got a tip.
Fuck Joe going to blow your fucking
socks off the whole fucking room.
Like just shit.
The priests just ran out of that
motherfucker Maguire. That's who it was.
I think that that might've been who I,
cool. I call, I call me you
and Chris Mcguire and beer
joing at that dot. I'm good.
We did.
The priest was there with my dad that
we did at [inaudible] on Friday night,
but we did grow 93 on Saturday night.
That's where I end up that way.
Or not monster fucking,
I was booed off stage.
I got booed off stage where I followed a
Jim brewer wants yeah. Nanuet New York.
I think it was maybe not manual
it somewhere somewhere in the uh,
outside of New York. It was
humiliating. Died, died,
a brutal, horrible death. I didn't,
I didn't know how to get myself out
of a bad mindset back then. And if I,
if anything happened bad during the day,
if I got in a fight with a check,
anything that went wrong, I could
spiral on stage. Like I can do good,
I can hold it together.
But I really had no business headlining
and brewer was having good sets all week.
We're both having good senses,
fun crowds.
But on the last show on Saturday night,
it was a late show and the crowd was
fucking drunk and he felt he fucking
killed.
And I was standing backstage and I,
this is one of my manager had just
convinced me to start dressing nice.
So I was wearing like club pants,
I'm wearing like a nice pair of slacks
and some nice shoes and I looked like the
most unfunny fuck on earth and I knew
it and I felt it like I'm like dressed
like this fucking stylish douche bag
and I'm going to go on stage and I don't
dress like this. This is not how addressed
if I was hanging out with my friends,
like this is not comfortable,
this is a fucking the close of an asshole.
And so I felt a backstage,
I was like, Shit. I'm like,
I can't be thinking like this.
I can't be thinking that I
shouldn't be dressed like this,
but I couldn't help it. And I might,
knee was fucked up at the time.
I had just gotten my ACL, just
tore. I hadn't had the surgery yet,
so I couldn't move good on stage.
If I moved funny one way or another,
my leg would pop out. So I had
all this shit in my head like, oh,
what if my knee pops out?
Fuck, I don't feel funny.
And I went on stage and just a dick.
I mean,
every joke that came out of my mouth,
I didn't know how to say it right.
My timing was off.
I was panicking.
And the worst part about it was this
dude fucking in the crowd goes, man,
you're not fucking funny.
And I couldn't say anything to him.
I couldn't say anything to him.
Cause I know he's right. You know,
all I can say to him as you're not
helping, this is not helping, you know?
But there's nothing in that, you know,
just pointing out that he's an asshole.
He knows he's an asshole.
He thinks
he's entitled to be an Asshole. He paid
to see my shitty act, you know? And, uh,
that was a huge learning point for me,
man,
about the mindset that you have
to have when you go on stage,
when you're young and you're,
you know,
your life is in disorder and
you go on stage like that,
you could have a goddamn tailspin
over,
you have to accomplish to a
mom and one and at the FEC rank
addressed the fucking elephant in my head.
Oh Shit.
I'm fucked. No, you're
going to be fine by, listen,
this isn't that. Joey and I are
going to come with, all right.
I'm going to come with Brian and I will
come with the kit will come with you.
I am. Fuck. We're going to be whatever
you past that. I don't smoke pot.
You're on mushrooms,
power mushrooms. Oh God.
What do you expect? Just throw out a
quick disclaimer. A smoke a second.
That's how wide you motherfuckers got me.
I really have no concept of fucking tired.
Like I was still worried about it, man.
Don't worry about, don't worry about
it. Let it go. Talk to them like,
this is what it seems like an okay,
I'm going to help you right here.
I'm gonna help you right here.
You're tripping. I'm not,
so let me take care of everything.
You live on this weed. You're fine.
The mushrooms, you're not afraid of.
The weed is what's freaking out and
there's more where that came from.
Cox introspective juice, Bro. It taps you
into the fucking nature of the universe.
He's just getting out the fucking problems
that I had my head and then we'll,
I'll be fine now.
I just wanted to say,
I really don't have any concept of time
right now. Good, good. That's good.
I got it. Well then I had to
just yet. So you can good.
You set it so that now it's
my responsibility. I'm going
to get you to your show.
Who you're working with tonight.
I'm not worried about anything,
but I want you to not thought out because
I was looking at you kind of melting,
like wanting to say, but I didn't want
to interrupt. Your story is a fuck baby.
Look at me with these glasses on.
So I'm not fucking 22 fucking kicking
on the couch saying and called nine one
one. Stan hope. And I did the weird thing.
I had to get out of my standup and I did
DMT and Stan hope went into like almost
like a semi seizure. And uh, it was
the only time I'd ever been right.
Anybody who did DMT. Yeah, that's
what you, when you came out,
but before you came out of it,
you were moaning manual like this
and it was like you got knocked out dude.
It was the same sound that a guy makes
when he gets brutally knocked out.
When a guy just gets fucking smashed.
They have this [inaudible] guy last night,
the ultimate fighter. The first fight.
I didn't see the fights last night.
Fucking spoiler alert, Joey. Well,
I don't know who it happened to,
so thanks for not saying
the names, but a, I'm a,
I'm going to go check it out
tonight. This weekend, man.
I wish you could come around this
weekend. Busiest weekend. Dot.
My rarest common [inaudible] come
to the fights. Are He's coming? Is he a
working with Damo? Rare in Vegas? No, no,
he's just coming down to see the fights
and there's a perfect, you know dom,
I ray was really good at pool and
don my rare play and I play pool.
Sometimes we're going to go
watch some professionals gamble.
There's this thing called the action
report.com and they have like professional
pool players and they have these big high
level gambling matches where they all
pool together like 50 a hundred thousand
dollars and you know like the buy in is
usually like $10,000 each guy and then
they bet a bunch of money on the side.
Brian,
that shit is really distracting.
I'm trying to put something on and
just drag a light side distracting. Is
this Joey's breathing
like Darth Vader. I was an opiate Anthony
the other day and I was listening to,
it was in my car and Bobby Kelly, he's
like show, what are you fucking breathing?
What's up with your breathing? And I
didn't hear it when I was on the phone,
but then I was listening to the radio.
I have a stupid headset and it sits in
front of my nostrils. So as you know,
I'm talking to him.
I don't even realize I'm doing this.
Like the whole camp.
It was the most annoying
fucking thing ever.
So they're all you who are listening
that day. I'm really sorry.
I did not know that. I was making those
annoying noises in the background.
That's going to be some great fights this
weekend and motherfucking next weekend.
Yeah, absolutely. I Jon Jones but cheated.
You got some John George Allen
Burger gets Diego Sanchez.
Eve Edwards versus El Kukui on Spike TV.
Oh Shit.
What about fucking Phil Davis Against
Russia? They're finally doing that.
You're going to Japan. I love and am at
Bisping. It's going to be a crazy fight.
Fight, fight. We agree. Fucking
fat. I wish she were going
to be there. Yeah, we'd go.
Ari should is going to be there.
The and gentleman and he's also going to
be playing his famous Ra shift fear non
UFC sponsored non UFC sanction. Hunt for
the edible. I don't know what that means,
but uh, if you want to follow it and I
have no connection to this whatsoever.
Go Duh, Ra should fear on
Twitter at a r I s h a f, F,
I r and he may or may not
be hiding. We'd play, sorry,
I'm going to see on Fox are we showed
up with a bag of Carmelo's are we always
had is 29,000 edibles close by the
other day I called my wife gets savage.
I call him up. I can't believe
I'm in traffic. Goes now,
you know I always have weed in my car
and he talked me into roll the joint on
the four oh five he goes roller.
Who gives a fuck? Smoke it.
You rolled it while you're stuck in
traffic. Yeah, it's beautiful wood.
Fucking handle old school.
You know what I like man,
I don't mind being in my car and traffic.
As long as I got that hands free system,
I could talk to people on the phone.
It's not bad man. You have
a conversation, you know,
I have like a nice long conversations
with friends. When you catch up, catch up,
phone calls,
you've been everybody's texting.
That's all everybody does is text these
days. You know the calls to calls to tax.
It's like text is five to one,
you know.
Have you been doing any of the Syria
Siri texting while you're in the car now?
As soon as I found out that Siri goes
to a fucking database, I just said,
why am I doing this? Yeah, everything you
do goes to a database. And I was like,
I don't like talking about that fucking
shit that we were talking about this
another thing. Yeah. Well you know,
apparently that was in a I o s um,
the iPhone operating system,
uh,
for in a diagnostic mode
only back in the day,
but it's not in it like android phones.
What John,
Bryan and I are talking about some new
thing that came out. What is it called?
Iq Client Iq.
Client.
Is there a reason why they say it's
in there? They have, they really,
I don't think anybody's
figured it out yet.
It's just been recently discovered and
what it is for the folks who don't know
what the fuck we're talking about when
you buy an android phone. Doug, Stan,
hope you have an android phone
now. All right. You're fucked up.
You should have went iPhone.
I know you tried to be a nice contrary
and go against the tide. I W I got what?
They use a window. Go get her to
those things I can fucking see.
So I don't have to put on reading glasses.
Well they apparently,
every time you send a text it logs it
in a database somewhere. It's stores.
He prays every,
every number you practice,
everything you do is logged
in a database somewhere.
My girlfriend doesn't
get on the line much.
So will you tell him that's not
even it do this Joe wrote? No, no,
it's not that.
I don't think it's that.
It's been proven and that's
where it gets interesting.
It's not that I don't think other
people have done it. I mean,
I think the FBI and the CIA
has been trying to do this,
trying to have the ability
to spy on people. And you
know, the argument is, well,
if you know doing wrong, what
are you worried about? Yeah,
but that's not the
point is it can be done.
So it will be just so he could get
doors database like, yeah, but it's,
and then manipulate that.
That's a qualification, that
argument, that argument.
Like if you're not doing anything wrong,
what are you worried about it?
But that's a shit argus in your fucking
life. They shouldn't be then finding,
let me film you poop. I want to see how
much you do. You look at the paper is,
you're not doing anything wrong.
Let me do it. Let me watch them.
I want somebody to know how many
times did do happy faces, you know,
or stupid stuff like that.
I do happy faces all day.
What's wrong with that?
Are still stuck in their business.
At the other end of this fucking wire,
there's the human being that does
that and he'll be dead with all that
information we give. So it's not that
man. You know what the real picture is?
It's not that.
The real picture is,
is that we're losing all of our secrets
and it's going to come to a point in
time where there will be no secrets
at all. Yeah, absolute honesty.
But yeah, it was like you
can't fight this. It is a
compelling thought, but it's,
you know,
everyone's terrified of it because
it's being controlled by a group of us.
It's by one, one, one group of
the population, the people who,
you know have this information
that's being controlled by them.
And we don't like the idea of anybody
having any control over any of us because
we know it's natural human nature
to want to dominate people.
So when you see something like this
and it was just a database that records
everything, you're fucked.
That's inevitable, right?
I mean if this is the
direction that it's going,
if you look at like just
how interconnected everybody
is with Facebook now and
you know, you just look at like,
that's a reason Twitter, it's going in,
going in that direction.
The person in the cubicle next to you
is now a celebrity because she can ego
surf herself and go, Yo,
I can candy Stouffer is
a fucking cunt. She talks too loud
and her breath smells like, yeah.
That's just because the fucking person
next to you in the cubicle that you bitch
at every morning is Facebooking about you.
So yeah,
and you could get famous where
with one fucking youtube video,
you're going to have one youtube video
you put up there and you can get famous
and you'll be as famous as the
next youtube video unless you,
you're really good at. But that's a
good thing. Yeah, it is a good thing.
The whole thing is amazing. It's
remembering clear channel. Yeah.
Just the word struck. Fear of
the, of what? A fucking corporate,
I don't even know if they exist anymore,
if it does. Well, because there's,
this is what matters. Yeah.
Podcasts. What people,
I was about to dump serious because,
but now you're getting a show on Sirius,
but on Sirius for awhile. On Saturday
and Sunday. But it fucking dump it.
Who gives a shit? No, no, no.
Don't go, hey Joe, you don't
want to dump serious, right?
I love series. I'm just not till I find
knew I could get it in my car. I'd listen.
I got to fucking drive an hour and a
half to an airport. You can get any car.
I get serious, dude. Yes. Every weekend
we're on the opiate Anthony Channel.
I wish we had just announced
the opie and Anthony Chao.
We should get free passes from serious.
At least we could give Doug a free year,
right? Yeah. We pay for our
own serious talk. Good about
serious here. But uh, yeah,
it's fun. Cool. I love the fact
that you can be in the car.
Like I and I listened to series every day.
I listen to OPA Anthony basically every
day riding fas and I listened to the
news. There's a lot of good talk radio
stations. I have this built in thing.
I can't get the XM things for some
reason. Really? Why is that? Well,
maybe I haven't. No, you
can't. You can't now either.
Maybe you just need to up
your prescription. CNN,
BBC
music on my fucking presets.
Now it's all sag vinyl cause every now
and then I'll hit it for a goof and
something go. Ooh. Yeah, I forgot that
one for record player in your car.
Fuck. Get it. Oh Brian,
you buffoon bright shirt.
What the fuck bro?
Come on and talk dog. It's only four
30, 30 cops. I'm trying to stay.
I just fucking the time guys. Yeah, no,
I just go to my,
watch it on the table.
Like I dropped a bomb on me late.
So, um, are you coming December 30th?
That UFC Brock Lesnar vs Alistair Overeem?
No,
I'm gonna do New Year's with you. Okay.
We're gonna do, we're going to do a,
um, um, a Vegas show in February
around like Superbowl time.
Yeah, we're going to do another way
to the Mandalay bay, a big one. A.
Does anyone in the UFC did any
of the fight areas? Not like you?
I get along with pretty much everyone.
Yeah. I don't have any problems with it.
If I do what I always straighten
it out. It's, you know,
it's a difficult thing when you're
criticizing people. Exactly. That's
fuck out of you.
And you're criticizing them about their
ability to beat the fuck out of each
other and you gotta go, look, man,
I'm not saying I can do it better
than you because that's the automatic
presumption. I'm just saying this is
what you're doing wrong. I can see it.
The WHO's fighting for that
soup bowls a Saturday. Who?
Who's fighting the Superbowl earlier?
Did you set,
this thing's not finding the fucking guy
from the show again in Bisping's fight
and ma'am. Oh, okay. Yeah. Oh
yeah. Oh No. I thought I heard
a different name. Like, no,
they're fighting and they're
fighting this weekend.
This is a fucking huge fight for Ma'am
and for, you know, for Bisping this,
you know, it just brings him into like
top contender status. If he beats mayhem,
you know, he's, he's right up
there with everybody else. Bam.
Have credits other than the stupid,
yeah,
fraudulent VH. It wasn't fraudulent. They
there was irresponsible perhaps, but a
fraudulent from a, just a
viewer's level like, Oh yeah,
they have a beef and they're
gonna Change Cock sucker.
That's a change I don't see.
I'm on the UFC small.
They don't have the super bowl
as big as it. That's how big
is it? It's more of a jar.
She don't have the Superbowl card up here,
unfortunately.
We can all talk about Joey jingles.
Watch your fucking change jar people.
What's he goes, that's your new
nickname? Only until we jingle.
The only time I got in trouble I was feel
change out of cars and shit. Which one?
That was on open.
Miker opened micro and I sold cars and
at night I was living in the city and I
needed a change to get back
over the fucking bridge.
We'd steal quarters or dimes to get
a doll 35 or something, but this is,
it was one of those periods and this shit,
this is what you always have to worry
when when when your friends are telling
you they don't do drugs,
that's when you worry about them.
When they are fucking doing heroin.
Fucking sage all night.
That's a guy you can trust, right?
It's the guy. No, I cleaned up Jay.
Just do you need anything?
You need me to house
sit while you're gone.
I cleaned up with some
fucking crazy times.
They'll just some crazy fucking
times, man. It really don't.
Hollywood Joey jingles thing
is like young Hollywood doing.
I hope he's not really fast, crazy days.
A weird thought that came into my head,
but I remember being at
the coach, coach, coach,
coach and horses. Yeah. Coked up
to the point where I couldn't talk.
Looking to my left and seen James Gamble
Feeney there with two of the hottest
fucking blondes.
You ever seen your life ready to get?
His Dick sucked looking at me and he's
is whacked up as I am looking at me and
be looking at him going to be
fucked up with that friend of yours.
The girl, I mean that was me and Hedberg
went in there as when he lived on Syrah,
Beneatha's fucking staying on his couch
and we went in there as like a like a
day
or we were day Jerry like we always
walked past and it's right up the fucking
street, but then they realize how cool
it was and the no one was in there.
There's, they had this bartender named
ginger ginger. It was like fucking,
it's throw momma from the train,
you know Mama,
she was that fucked up and she was like,
and she was covered in the liver
spots or rank sores or whatever. No,
she fucking, they booted. This is
all fucking nineties but yeah, they,
they've, she had been a bartender there
for, since its heyday before. Wow.
You know how dive bars
go then they go through.
So they couldn't fire her in those old
alcoholic random, but she, she was like,
she threw a blind guy out
of the bar for having a dog.
They go guards.
And then the regulars that knew
her were trying to explain no,
it's a seeing eye dog. He's a
boy. He's blind. I don't care.
No dogs. Wow. Like horrific
fucking human being.
You'd be sitting in it, sit
at the bar and, and you,
your drink is out and
I,
good.
No one was listening to me so I just
got thrown off the sound of Joey's
breathing and the silence together.
It was just starving for what?
You'd have an empty drink and she'd
go out, ed and I did like and,
and people would say, uh, no,
I'm good right now. And you
go, this isn't a bus stop.
Wow. Like there was, that's why there was
no one in there. But then you'd fucking,
next thing you know you're doing it was
Quintin Tarantino at they were doing is
me and like Hedberg and Quentin Tarantino
and that's it in this dive shit hole
did it. It's closed now, right?
Yeah. It's when we play,
the place is closed,
but we still get tennis rackets
and play time pictures of it. Yeah.
We haven't Hedberg. And what was the
kid with the long hair from Seattle?
I was an Ireland doing comedy
and he was Shard Hogan.
Oh my God. All those guys. And
then say Fulton Day full.
Yeah, he's staying home.
How to rent a car that was
in front of his house. Again,
you could just jump in it and
drive it whenever you need it.
But the gas gauge was broken.
I got busted one time as Santa Monica.
Sam is sent day.
I'd fucking rush hour because you know,
you're just getting a car.
I have an audition standup.
I'm in a bind. Take the car,
boom, getting a fucking car
ran out of gas. Oh my God,
don't fucking is the gas gauges
broken fucking idea. Another night,
Stan hope is out of town or something
like that, and he goes, take the cost.
So lean.
And so he goes,
take the car and just bring it
to stand hopes in the morning.
I parked it on sunset.
They've fucking toe it.
The whitening of $200 for the
white via tended to fucking motor.
When you lived in Venice in that house
that was painted like the American flag
painted and right after nine,
this giant as a duplex and they,
it was fucking giant stars
in the fucking stripes.
Oh, so, so super bowl weekend is a Diaz
versus Saint Pierre. That's what it is.
Shit. Yeah. I don't know if a saint
peers fully repaired those repair.
He had an injury he had
from listing to Diaz healed.
The fucking thing just yielded. I hope so.
A lot of other fights or Carlos condit.
Josh Cox. Let's stop fucking
talking like fans and talk like men.
We don't watch GSP for
his knees. All right. Oh,
keep wearing those tight fucking shorts.
I love you motherfucker.
You suck that he shaved. Is that what
it is? I don't know what it is. Sunday,
we're going to have a show here at the
ice house. Apm. Is that what it is? Brian
podcast starts at seven shows that eight
o'clock powerful gentleman, Joe Diaz.
Ladies and gentlemen, follow
him on Twitter. It's mad
flavor. Mad Flavor bitches.
Funniest fucking guy in the
world. Love you too, man.
I'll see you Sunday.
Jesus. Powerful Joe. Yes.
Ralphie may was making out with your mom.
Oh yeah, we were. Whoa. Wait a minute.
We haven't talked about
my, yeah, they cats.
I fucking sad. I still talk
about that. My Act sale.
It's then,
well this cat died,
so she had a wig for the cap that you put
a little towel and she put the fucking
towel and she had all the cats sit
around the dead cat and look at them and
express their condolences.
To the guy and I told Mrs [inaudible]
was the stay at home. She goes,
look at them.
They love the categories.
Then little love this sitting
around and going, I need that.
And that way I think that tail,
because everybody was busy.
Something my mother was great,
was a cat,
was missing a leg that belonged
to mrs family. Fuck it.
That leads me into plugging
to December 10th,
December 10th Tucson fucking
Joey Diaz has he shown up.
Shawn Rao says he showed us
what we already have. Brendan,
Brendan Walsh, Brody Stevens,
Saturday, December 10th.
What does it offer yet?
The reality though,
theater in a Tucson. Oh no,
sounds awesome. What does,
it's why it's of
benefit for the humane society.
Oh really? Every fucking penny. I'm
paying comics. Fucking airfares.
Really? Oh, that's that things coming
out of the gate. I got that surgery.
I'd have fucking umbilical hernia.
So I just put on my website as a joke.
Is it? Uh, yeah. Uh, I have this,
I described the problem is that
it's a belly button hernia,
which is your fucking intestines
pouring your guts. Oh my God.
But the fatter and older I got,
the more pronounced it became and people
are like, you got to get that check.
Anyway, I put on my
website, I'll give you a, if
you're a surgeon out there,
I'll give you a free DVD if you
me free surgery and I got it.
Really? Yeah, free surgery.
What does it like
cutting under some a fan.
It's going to put you under and opioids
out fucking w wilds and whites of West
Virginia. Fucking oxycotton. I
can fix anything kind of surgery.
It was a respectful dot.
No,
they were anesthesiologists that were
fans and you look like Robert Deniro at
some points and I'm trying to fucking
ignore a lot of things that are going on
in my head. Which Robert
Deniro, the Cape Fear One.
I don't know your fucking
heads just does that naturally.
Kind of twisting out of
control, dude, dude, dude, dude.
Dude,
that's so funny.
So hope story all going to be groovy.
Yeah. This the story. Who knows?
Could be anything. What? Any idea what
his story was about. I can't remember.
Something about Ralphie may make it out
with your mom. That's right. Yeah, I know.
That's what it was supposed to. It's
where I was supposed to go. Yeah.
What was I fucking, was I talking
about my mother? No, I think,
I think Joey Diaz just did one of those
things where he just ran out and it's
like, oh, I might drop this
bomb and run flux. Your head up.
So important man. This guys like
him. So important. It's so important.
And you meet dudes that are
just out there on the fringes.
We were randomly talking about this last
night or this morning about like people
that you know that are funnier than
any comics, you know, they fucking die.
There's that. Oh, comedy
lost a massive, no,
that was a funny dude at a bar I have.
I have so many people I know that how
many a lot of things and they just never
get into stand up.
But my manager is funnier than me
and I know it fucking destroys it.
Really genuinely brilliant and
funny and my manager's funny.
My business manager's funny.
My business manager as funny as comics
are funny, he can be a comic, he can eat,
they can easily, both of them could have
been comics if they want it to be. Yeah.
I know a lot of people that could have
been comics. There's a lot of them,
you know, and it's, it's a funny thing.
It's who decides to take that road?
Who decides not to. Same, but you know
those people that could have done it. Man,
they're the same type of people to
be around. You know, some of the,
the guys that used to
hang out with at the pool,
funniest fucking human beings
I've ever met. They're just,
they're just derelicts gambling junkies
and they're just wild motherfuckers just
due to, they weren't fitting in
into some nine to five suit job.
It wasn't working out for them.
And it wasn't even like comics where
comics tried to say something funny on
purpose. Exactly. Funny people. Exactly.
They're not working on it right now.
Working on a bit. Yeah. Joey Diaz
just fucking, I mean, come on.
What is cliche is, yeah, you may
a phone book, but he's that funny.
Do you remember the early days when
dudes would actually try bits on you?
That's the worst. Oh yeah. No, I
still get it. I do it all the time.
You do it all the time to people? Uh, I
don't do, I don't like it. It's not a bit,
it's something I think of that
it's funny and I'm just like, oh,
I'll just say it out loud
to see if I think it's fun.
Everyone thinks it's funny or if you know,
but it's not like I'm,
I've been writing this bit for many, many
weeks and I can't, you know what I mean?
Like it's more, it's something
I just thought of maybe
like that minute, you know,
you're not sure they
try it out on people. I don't really,
I don't think about trying it out loud.
If you're saying, hey listen, I'm working
on this bit. Do you have any ideas?
They'll,
he'll just fucking forced me.
I won't even say what city
because cause he'd know.
But there was a comic like a old,
like fucking 30 some plus years
in the business in the green room.
Hey, haven't seen you in so
long. You haven't worked out.
And he's starts telling me I can give
it away with that voice I now know is
knowing you. You probably know.
Yeah, no, it's, no, no, no.
I am I talking, I'm fucked up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Black British. Sorry. So happy.
I'm targeting this. Oh, sorry.
Anyway, no, no, I'm good. I'm good.
I'm going to fucking power
through this up. Oh yeah.
So he is fucking rifts. All these jokes,
but that bad, like from the new Eh,
as trying to my station,
but he's doing a guest set and then goes
immediately from the green room and has
the exact same conversation we just
had in the green room as a set.
Oh, you know what he did?
He just ear fucked you.
He just made you sit and listen
to his sets so he could warm up.
That's what he did. It was, I mean, it
was almost immediate. Like, Hey, wow,
perfect for him. He's like, if I
can get it off in front of Stan,
hope probably be fine. But it was
someone I've known for like, yeah,
but he doesn't care.
Here's is,
here's these people that are basically
almost sociopathic. You know, their,
their desire to succeed,
desire to like do well on stage supersedes
everything, supersedes being a human,
you know,
and they don't care if they just use
you to get their shit off and practice
before they go onstage.
Stage in my friend, I'm gonna
practice on you. You know,
your friends suck my Dick.
They just in the mouth,
they're just ear fucking you
instead of fucking your mouth.
They're fucking your ear.
Like they want to get off on your mouth.
They can't fin again had the uh,
their talk blockers talk bloggers.
I was Christian Finnegan. That's
a good way of putting it. Yeah.
There's people that just want to talk
at you, man. That's the cocaine effect.
I don't know what that is, but
I've noticed, you know, I'm,
I'm very ignorant to the
effects of cocaine. The only,
the only insight that I have is the
one time that you and I drank that co,
that Mata de cocoa tea. It was
the same, same time that we,
the whole day of the war. Oh yeah.
All right. And I remember saying,
I can't shut the fuck up. Like I got a
real problem. I cannot shut the fuck up.
I'll give you,
I'll give you an analogy that might work.
You know when you're like
you're writing really well. Yes.
And you're like fucking I,
I this to Bingo. You fucking
just be with me cause it,
my head's going faster than I can write
and I just bounce ideas off of her on
PR. That's the cocaine is
like where you're fucking
okay, I'm rapid cycling. No,
you need to hear this. Cause my
fucking brains going. And so,
but it's two people doing that at the
same time and it's all fucking pointless.
And it's a bad note book. It's in organic.
Yeah. Well his Adderall, the medium then,
cause a lot of people that are on Adderall
day, they, they mean, but what is it,
what's the difference between
the cocaine high in a speed high?
Well I know Adderall is very
much a lot like cocaine.
It makes me feel like I'm meeting
getting drips because it just is like a
constant reminder that it feels
like I'm on cocaine and I, but wow.
But it seems like it lasts
longer and like where cocaine,
you feel this like up and then like
15 minutes later sold web for me.
Adderall. That just gives me anxiety.
That's a long term. Like I don't, I,
I liked the uh, the seller, what do you
call it, the, the practice of doing coke.
I like shopping up and doing
a line is really romantic
and if you do it in a fucking comedy,
like the comedy store, Green Room of the,
the main stage green room at
the comedy store, just like,
I want to chop up a ramp mirror.
It's just kind of
mirrors the weird piano.
It's hilarious.
You do read Buller's like
I can do. Yeah. Boom. Okay.
I do a bump and I move on with my life.
It's like fucking energy drink now.
Yeah. Really? Wow. That's, it's, yeah,
it's the, the whole act of it is,
I was on the highway once, I was like
18 years old. I was with my friends,
we were driving home and we were in
revere. We're near a Kelly's roast beef.
It's fucking really sketchy neighborhood
with a great place to get fried clams.
And, uh, as we're driving,
we see this car beside us and the
people in the backseat had the light on.
They had the dome line on and they were
doing coke and the girl looks over at me.
I looked at her and
she'd just come the fuck,
she just looks at me and has this
fucking evil look at her face. Fuck you.
And I'm like, Whoa, how to know.
All I did was look over at you,
caught you doing coke and she's
gone. And I was like, okay. So,
but it was weird how a little thing like
that will scare you off of it. Yeah.
There was that. The first
time I did acid, I puked.
We lived in a Vegas. We're, uh,
I lived with this family where
I'll like renting from her,
but there was kids in the fucking,
they'd play basketball in the
driveway every day and like, you know,
eight to 12 years old every day.
The first time I did acid,
we took it and I'm having a fun time
and I'm like, this is fucking good.
And then we went back in for a second
hit and I put the acid on my tongue and
then we walked back out into this.
I'm fucking tripping hard
and there's a bunch of kids,
little kids playing basketball
and someone threw me
the basketball.
So I inhaled still had the paper on
my tongue and it stuck to the fucking
cliteracy in the back of your throat.
So I puked into my mouth
in front of kids were,
but I'm consciously thinking I don't
want to lose the hit of acid that I just
put. So I'm, I have a mouth
full of puke trying not to.
So I tried to swallow the Puke,
which makes you puke way
harder than anything else. Oh.
So I just, I extreme vomit in front
of all these horrified children.
It's four in the afternoon
and I start picking through the BW
cause I, so I don't want to listen.
I don't want to lose that hit of acid.
Oh my God.
I found the acid in my previous
work it off and my beer neck.
What are you even still work? The, the,
the looks on the faces of
the children where some guy,
your neighbor Guy Kinda guy is coming out
and now he's rummaging through his own
vomit the afternoon.
Oh,
such a beautiful image and that might
queer those kids off and do an acid is my
point. I, you know what? Yeah,
much like you are queered
off coke from a finger stick.
Some men and a mullet rummaging through
his vomit on its side street in Vegas.
Oh my God. That might make you think it
was one of the best nights of my life.
Did you tell us it was one of the fucking
trip was still legendary like yeah,
just from eating. Did you think when
you put it back in your mouth it,
it hit you harder? Oh
boy. It was a second hit.
The point is the, no, we,
it was my first time tripping so I was
already on one hit and wanted more.
Of course,
let's do more.
Wow.
Yeah, that probably did queer
them off. It probably just much.
Is it okay to say queer,
the Moffett? No, I'm just,
I'm just so happy I remembered why I
started this story is because you were
talking about the cocaine and the woman.
That seems like 40 minutes ago.
It was a long time ago. Really? I'm so,
it was weird when you started
taking a nap. Just right there.
You took it like a little nap.
Do you remember?
Did I drive some fucking with
you? Don't. Don't do that Brian.
Tell fuck with dudes that are tripping.
All Con. That was not fucking, I'm sorry.
All right, fellow settle
though. Your cigarette went out.
I never knew cigarettes went out. Yeah.
Why? I guess I talked for a minute.
I thought cigarettes just designed to
burn a lot of this show that I was just
sitting listening to in my car and
I'm like, oh wait, I'm on at fuck.
I got to talk.
I was just a huge fan sitting back
Mac for a while in California,
they actually have these new cigarettes
where they stopped burning after a
certain parts of California.
We were talking about that like that
was a fad, like childproof lighters,
but it's a California thing. Well,
I don't know if it's all California,
if they just them for all cigarettes
by it so that people,
when they flick them out their windows,
they will go out and not
pillow and catch a fire. Yeah,
it seems like it would be. How did they
do that? What kind of chemical is that?
Who knows what the fuck they're
putting in there anyway,
the FDA food and drug
administration as it is, they uh,
they approved more than 500 different
chemicals that are in cigarettes.
Well that's fantastic for Philip Morris.
Just put,
did you buy stock more stock or
the day my fucking accountant, the,
you know,
do some mobile your money or
something so that he talks to you.
Well know it is just accountant
Brendan Walsh. I would know it.
That's how I hear it.
It's just for trying to tell
me about a rainy day. Like,
am I actually said that to him?
I go,
I don't really have that much
confidence in saving for later.
So yeah, let's just keep
it in the bank. Well,
you can't get it all right.
That's all I care about.
It's kind of hope it's still
real. Right? But yeah, no,
I had to get comedy accounts.
They are very cool. But
it was when,
when,
when they're trying to talk to you
real businesslike and you go, yeah,
it probably won't be alive
then. Ooh, how do we talk?
So you got to an a accountant
that's just a regular dude.
You don't know the comics account and he
has like 500 comics and I want to name
drop and my camera, he still
doesn't think it's something Jewish.
So he's still sharp. Harvey
Altman, Harvey Altman and his kid.
They're fucking big comedy fans.
Well that's cool.
So what he's trying to do is hear
shysters and we'll find out soon.
Should I said those happen upon occasion.
They've done well by me.
You've been shyster no, I said I've
done well by you. That was my plug.
I have to always mention Harvey Altman.
Have you?
I stutter and tried to remember his name.
Have you heard about this new
fucking thing that's going down,
this new bill that they're trying to
define the United States first up.
First of all, them don't fucking ona
me where you're talking to your laptop.
I just want to make it seem like I'm
around wondering why I don't talk for 30
minutes for a second.
Even fucking doors.
Even Norton sits on there.
What is,
he's constantly just looking
at his cell phone. Fucking, oh,
I guess is always staring
at a laptop and you're like,
what the fuck is it does ruin the flow.
You're correct.
I just wanted to get your take.
Always thought.
I always thought it was closing like
every time you do. Oh, and a, I love them.
They're all great people. There's
no pretense with them, but it all,
it all seems like they're
going out of business. Like
what do you mean? They just
have that attitude of, yeah,
anytime they're going to start taking
boxes out here because we're all just
watching like they'd done.
It's not even like for the show,
like you're looking up
something for the show.
They're just firing around why
they're working. Oh, that's funny.
Norton's fucking twittering.
It's a problem when nobody stops
everybody from doing that. She,
I went on there last time. I felt like,
are we really on the air so easiest?
Just fucking check your
Twitter all the time.
I think it's just because
they do it every day.
Can you imagine doing this every
day? For what? For six hours.
How long do they craziness. Yeah.
What we do is a lot, and it's still,
don't get me wrong, no problem.
Very manageable, but yeah,
it was a very comfortable, but it was
like where you go. I would just say, hey,
we're just four of us hanging out.
They're just so comfortable
with hanging out there.
It doesn't seem like from minutes
I'll come on. You don't know.
It just seem like that when
you're in there you're,
that's my favorite show to do
because when you do that show,
it's just like you're hanging out. It
doesn't feel like you know, so many shows.
It's like you feel like you're upright,
you're posture is upright and you're just
trying to give a good presentation and
then you leave. You know
you're like, this is,
I never feel like I connected with these
people, but you know, you go to ona,
it's just a hangout and
people just walk in. You know.
He had those people walking in the hall,
just claim one owned the place and
it was Marion Barry walked in once,
Marion Barry and we were asking a
questions about smoking crack. Yeah,
but this was in the hallway water.
Then the amount of energy dice clay can
still put into being dice cloud and you
don't use a master. You have
no idea. What's an act like?
I'm talking to north and he's my friend.
I'm going to like how much it is that
that's what it's like on the road.
And they like, well, you're not
telling me if you don't know. Right.
Tamworth is real. Yeah. Well
he's got that, what's her name?
The great chick from the comedy store
and legendary Eleanor. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was immediately knew who it is. That's
who I was thinking. Oh, I don't know.
It's amazing. She's amazing. She is the
comedy store days. Yeah. When she's gone,
that place is dead. You know. They,
they don't have any of the old waitresses
working there and she's still there.
No, no, no, no. She's a comic
man. She's doing well. Oh fuck.
She's doing really well.
But all the waitresses. Dot.
There was someone over there.
Why Rating?
Look at Robert plays a giant fucking
half naked Robert Plant and cock. Right?
They're clearly defined.
That's an 18 foot ceiling and they're
projecting Robert Plant's fucking package.
While that's so weird,
he's kind of his balls and cocker clearly
on the left side of his parents. Yeah,
no, there's this, it's almost sculpted.
It's weird. It's not even real.
And the way he moves, like he would
be terrible at fucking, you know,
he's not like Bobbi Brown up there.
They haven't had a step back take.
They called that whiskey Dick. He
just looks like a, the way he moves,
he's like real awkward. He's a bond.
I wouldn't want him fucking me.
I'll tell you that. I'm like, come on
buddy. What's this? What are we doing?
Ever seen me dance, Joe, you never know
Robert Plants on the wall,
but they just didn't have the same
awareness back there. I don't think,
don't worry. No, it's
filming looked different.
They are though.
If you had an all time favorite band
led Zeppelin, is it up there? No, no.
Really Pink Floyd. The wall would
be like on my top five albums. Yeah,
I agree.
But also have counting crows and uh,
Tim Curry,
who no one knows his fucking music at all.
Tim Curry put as it really Tim curry
the actor. Yeah. Really from clue. No,
he had one kind of vague
hit with I do the rock.
I do the rock myself. No.
Oh yeah. And that was it.
Like he did rocky horror and then put out
two albums and then he was the lead in
rocky horror. Right. And he was thinking
that that wasn't it. Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
That guys are like a really good singer.
The kind of music,
he's kind of Robert,
Robert,
you putting him above us.
There's no Zeppelin album.
I want to sit on a fucking island
and listened to. That's crazy.
You're the ocean. But I don't like
music. I don't like it just fucking,
it just ruins conversation.
It does sometimes,
but it's great when you're
on airplanes. I, you know, I,
I read or I sleep. I
do too. I do those too.
But I also like listening to music
and writing. I hate music. Yeah. No,
I want to download it. And if
you're out to, if you're listening,
I want a lot of fucking like
big band swing, but no vocals.
That's what I want to listen
to when I write is no vocals.
I want to have that background, Huh? Yeah.
Background music. I do the same thing.
You know what I do? I do Spanish music.
They had fucking, Joe does radical.
Yeah.
It sounds just as an air of cunty right
around it makes me write Cunty Ralphie
may played the guitar.
Um, I don't know. No,
but he just didn't fucking die.
Like Ralphie May's in my death pool.
I had to put one comic. This is a for
money one. It's a real death pool.
Not like just a something we joke about.
This is for money. How much money?
50 bucks each person for a year.
How many people is only 11 people.
But next year we're going
to get this rock. And
I've never had more fun than being
in a death pool. Really call a say.
It's like having stocks.
Here's how they're checking the paper.
Like you can get super offended when
you put them in your death pool though.
Well I was,
I like,
I've had so many people I
front loaded celebrity rehab.
So Tom Sizemore if you're
listening, Jeez, you know what?
Fucking remember the of
crackle of that rock.
Gwendolyn.
The self confidence.
Get back with Heidi Fleiss I don't think
I need separate together cause I need
you to die by December 31st
cause I'm in seventh place.
My only death this year as Jeff Conaway
and I get some, Oh that guy died, huh?
Yeah.
Well there's a bonus
system like if you die,
if there's an overdose,
I get another 25 points for the
overdose and he was a scientologist.
He went to that after celebrity rehabs
of Scientology is another fucking
cytologist late in life
then very late, right? Yeah.
Because Dr drew didn't
work so he's trying,
can you pull up a video
of that guy all fucked up.
Cause I heard that on celebrity rehab.
He was super fucked up.
I heard it like a bunch of
different times but I never saw it.
Did you ever see it? Who?
The guy that got it done.
That's because I don't follow pop culture
celebrity Rehab because I hate Dr drew
was such a violent passion cause he's
a fucking scheister snake oil salesman
piece of shit.
I'll,
I'll all on a fucking the new DVD that'll
come out as soon as I can pick a cover.
Dr Drew is a good guy.
I liked back to drew.
That's why it was a real nice guy.
Think some more evil because
he believes what he's saying.
He says some crazy shit though.
He said some really ridiculous shit about
marijuana and the addiction properties
of it and the call effectiveness.
Again, he's, he's one of those like,
no this is part of the fraud. But he's
kind of adjusted his stance on that,
you know? And he's kind
of like, hey, you know,
this is what always pisses me off about
people when they have this just his
dance based on fucking the polls.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Well you know,
it's a personal freedom issue in anybody
that doesn't understand that it's
ridiculous.
And if it was really that bad,
there'd be a bunch of fucking
bodies attributed to it.
And there is none. And My,
my real problem with it is that they
always have this whole late at night and
Breyer. It might be just on a fucking
slab. Dude. You're going to be great.
Great. It's only five o'clock. I'm
good. Mad Time to three hours from now.
You'll be self deprecating and plugging.
Bray Bray improv tonight. Yeah.
W one show. What time? 8:00 PM.
If you're not listening to this,
then you'll have no idea why the
show went like that. Is it APM? Yeah.
I guess who's fucking like usually a pm
who's doing the show with you or your
family? When's death? Five always
fight. Always five. Always ate. Yeah.
You can't have a nutty
1145 show. I've got, I've,
I've played like three Improv's now.
It was three out of two out of three.
Three out of four where they hadn't
updated the fucking video screen.
Stop that fucking red band
right now. It's making me, dude.
You keep changing that and
it's distracting. It's told
me to show you the video.
Search the video for Jeff Conaway
and so I was going to play a video.
That's Doug's fans
giant that I'm against.
Okay. I love your head. Let's
play that Jeff Conway. We
thing. Let's see the other,
you got it up there.
Oh,
that's led Sappho.
Oh, he's over there. Oh Wow.
What's that music bro. Is that in
this? That's your fucking shitty music.
That's really in your iPod. Oh, play this
back. So I got to hear this guy's voice.
He's Jack. Dude. Put it early.
Subtitling it for a reason.
He's not making. I know, but
I want to hear the noises.
But that guy was fun. Eat. They showed,
this is back when they glorified
the priests story. Look at him,
dude.
Drugs Suck.
Killing myself. He said,
how would you do that?
Yeah.
Damn.
She muscle breaking him here.
True
with this.
Jesus was glasses.
I can break them,
could slit my wrists with them.
How amazing would it be if this guy didn't
do any drugs at all and this was like
a role he was playing to try to let people
know he can still fucking act. Yeah.
Yeah, and Dr Andrew is about to tell
him that fucking God will heal it.
Doctor June doesn't say that, does
he? Yeah. He's a fucking 12 stepper.
That's what Aa is.
They put you into a 12 step program,
but you're all about God.
I know why
they do that. I think it's a
mechanism. I agree with you that it's,
it's silly if you want to look at it
as far as like whether it's
plausible and crying. Hold on.
Same time and symbol guiding.
The audience talks to me.
He's just, you laughing. Are you crying?
I turned my head. I said, I'm laughing.
I'm crying.
Okay, killer telephone. Thank you.
If that guy was really acting, it's,
that's really wasn't how. It wasn't how
he really is. If he was just acting,
that would be brilliant. What a
great move. Somebody should do that.
You should go on celebrity rehab. I'd
like that. Yeah, but he wasn't doing it.
But what a great idea it would be
to show people how good you can act.
Go on celebrity rehab and just fake what
they stocked up. Oh, that's what they do.
They've had people on there
for a marijuana addiction.
They just know they're,
I think he said he's not doing it anymore,
which I hate because I love trashing.
He every take shit.
We've got that new CNN show now.
He's now he's trying to, you know, Oh, I'm
not just a doctor of sex and drugs now.
Now I'm a doctor of life.
You know, like yeah,
this sailor destiny or they become
celebrity doctors. Very tricky.
Like that CNN guy that Sanjay Gupta,
I look actually thanked him on my,
no refunds. Really? Why? I
just thanked weird people.
Just, it's a, it's a name
that sticks in your head.
That Syrup Sanjay Gupta next it
was Sunday. Stop with saying,
Sanjay Gupta,
fucking just make up another name.
So I put Sanjay Gupta back into the
universe instead of stuck in my like a
fucking leper.
That guy took a hundreds of thousands
of dollars for pharmaceutical companies.
It takes over a hundred thousand
dollars a year. A piece of shit who,
they're ridiculous.
I can't stand those fucking talking
about fucking white people's pieces of
Jacobs coming over here
and stealing our fucking,
where's that at? White Guy. He
used to hate Sanjay goop. Did okay.
Someone over here. It's taken
our corruption. Is that nonsense?
Say or wow. You're right buddy.
Yeah, no, I'm good. I'm good. I just,
I haven't been high and so fuck
it along. Is that what it is? Yes.
To not smoke weed at all.
I don't start at all.
That was like many years.
I've seen you turned down.
We'd like every single time until this
is the first time I think I've ever seen.
It's great, isn't it? I love it. I'm
intimidated. Why intimidated by, no, no.
I'm intimidated. I would. He made me smoke
pot. Oh, it was going around the table.
I didn't want to be the uncool kid.
When you said you were,
the only reason I even pass it to you
is cause you said before that I'm even
willing to smoke pot. Well I, I really
want it. It's so fucking available.
It's awesome. That's the thing.
I want to have a taste for it.
I want to stop fucking drinking so much.
The edibles, he knew. He didn't know why.
The animals have a totally
different effect man.
It's like really like a strong
psychedelic. Yeah. You know
you eat cookies, eat me.
He and he's fucking cookies at Joey takes.
It's like every other drug or alcohol.
I like.
It would be starting,
I'd be 18 years old,
which is what I feel like right now where
I'm just fucking stupid and forgetting
that we have to. I can entertain you
as we're fine. It's entertainment.
You're fine. You're fine. I know what
you're saying, but the point is, yeah,
I don't want to have to
start with, we'd like, okay,
how much can I spoke before show?
It always amaze me that
you were so introspective.
You're very introspective dude and you
don't have any ego problems and yet you
didn't smoke weed.
I always thought that was
really interesting because
it always made because it
was never a community thing. When
I get, when you trip with people,
you're all like weird together,
we're all fucking dog in this and
every time I smoked weed it seemed like
everyone was laughing
without me or at me and I,
it wasn't never felt. Maybe you
gave up on it like way too early,
maybe in your smoking with the wrong
people because if you're smoking them with
us, it's just a giggle fest.
You know, we just spoke,
we'd break down universe and laugh at
shit. Yeah, no smoking too much too,
but you're probably thinking it's like
a beer where you have to have many hits.
Honestly, I think like even before a show,
one hit, usually it would be awesome,
but he would want to do it,
but it's been so long since I actually
was like a teenage fucking weed smoker
and realize they don't,
I've given it plenty of opportunities.
The problem is there's two kinds of weed.
There's Endeca,
which is what you always get.
That's what you normally get in Florida.
It's where you get,
if you don't know a guy,
it's what you get if you're not educated,
indicates the stuff that makes you sleepy,
it makes you,
it's really bad for short term
memory loss.
Sativas not so great for it either.
Short term memories are a weird thing
with marijuana. It's almost like
the thoughts are coming at you.
So
I should be able to do when you can do a
fun. No, no, that's not what I'm saying.
I'm just saying there's two
different kinds of weed that the,
the indigo is probably what
you were getting all the time.
You probably weren't just saying
these are your legendary forgiven.
A dude that smokes pot a lollipop and
he can't get off the fucking couch.
All right.
Who was that telling me?
I know a lot of people that if fucking
tell him fucking yeah, it's supposed
to be bought. Like I couldn't move.
Well, you know what it is, man.
I like it hard. I like, I'm like,
if it's going to hit me, it knocked
me on my ass. I did say it. Yeah.
I want it to knock my my ass man. When
you take an edible, you know you want to,
you want to really blast off into the,
the ultimate,
like the furthest extent that you could.
You could,
but you function like that the same
way I function shit faced drunk. Yeah.
I don't always function perfectly around
like I got to because I spent 21 years
doing it. Like you're a fucking
a seasoned. We get hangovers.
I just feel like shit all the
time. Every day, every second,
no energy. I've quit smoking,
quit drinking coffee.
Rather I quit drinking
coffee like for the kids,
not just for a goof to see what
you don't like it when you,
I just sleep with the TV on
the shuttle bus to the other wing.
I uh, I took off a few days and then I
had a cup of coffee and it hit me like a
lightning bolt. I was like, Whoa,
is this what coffee normally like?
Cause usually I drink it.
I don't even feel it.
It's like I'm so used to
just drinking coffee. Like,
I'll have two cups of coffee in a day
and maybe even more when we're doing the
podcast. I'll just, I'll, I'll pound
down three while we're sitting there.
And then you don't realize that
your body just developed. Whoa.
We need to process this shit nice and
quick and we need to develop a fucking
tolerance for it. And then when
you don't have it for a while,
your body sort of normalizes and then
you'll have a coffee and it's like,
oh. Like it really jolts the
shit out of you. My nerve,
I attribute it to alcohol,
but my nervous system
when I drink coffee now,
a lot of times I just fucking
visibly shake just from a,
I drink decaf. Wow. But
I don't know if it's,
my nervous system is like that week
were just coffee affects it. You know,
you're fucking, you get older, you think
everything is attributed, does something.
Yeah. And I'm so happy when my
friends that don't drink all the time,
don't remember anything
like shit. Well, yeah,
mind a lot more than a lot of people.
I bet.
Just because of the fact you're always
writing and you're always performing.
You're always putting your act together
and organizing it and putting new shit
together and putting out DVDs.
But you
know, all of us, this doesn't
matter who you are, it's,
it's eventually this thing is
going to shut off. Well, yeah,
there's a water level high water mark
to how much fun you had and it has to be
more fun than that to
register. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Oh,
I get drunk with you in Indianapolis,
but that's happened how many
fucking decades in a row.
Okay. I don't remember you.
Did we fucking kill a guy that said,
I don't that you'd have to be you
dancers supersede other levels. Oh,
we went to a titty bar. Oh, did
I see tits there? Of course.
I remember you from 2002 fucking stupid.
There's been too many
decades and too many. Yeah.
It's interesting when you look at,
I've likened it to like if you went to
your entire public schooling comedy,
21 years of comedy.
It's like if you went to your entire
public schooling and then college and then
a couple of years of Grad work,
but you are shit faced every day for
your entire fucking schooling and in a
different school every week
and you come up and say,
do you remember me from eighth grade?
He's a fucking million.
Eighth grade's in this career.
And not only that, this just,
you think about the numbers of
people you meet every night.
You're brains are not designed for that.
Your brain is designed to meet like
50 people designed to have 100 handy.
Cause Richard Jenny,
when I was,
remember that the head of the class chick
I dated forever, the fucking Red Ed.
I was dating her.
And so she had done a,
a platypus man's like pilot for and and
so she'd be at the Improv and they'd
like hugging,
kissing.
You know how Richard Jenny was a bit
of a ledge and she introduced me as her
boyfriend. She goes, this
is my boyfriend Doug,
and I'm like this fucking cunt with a
mullet and the corner. And he'd go, yeah.
Anyway.
Anyway,
it's great to see you when I go out into
the thing and Sushi and late and he did
that a lot to me and then
he was hosting one night,
the fucking Montreal,
like one of the dirty you shows when
they are late night con tribes pieces.
Yeah. It's the danger zone.
And he was emceeing Richard,
Jenny, you know the dangerous
Richard Jenny on the danger.
Midnight fucking get
another 25 quids Audi.
He says, uh, I've never seen this next
comic before and I went to let it go.
You fucking hit on my
girlfriend all the time.
So you get like opening? Yeah, he, oh,
he introduces me. I've never seen it.
I've never met this comic before,
but I've heard good things that I
just opened with. He'd never met me.
Fucking try to hammer my girlfriend in
front of me like I'm nothing all the time.
Wow. He took it in good
spirit. Well till the end,
until he killed himself because I said it.
Do you think what really
ultimately triggered?
I'm pretty sure that was just a slow
burn by young fucking spirited Montreal.
One ranch has destroyed us office team.
Did you like him as a comic?
I, he had one of the fucking best bits
and I've tried to find it on the Internet
about uh,
something about playing the wreck
of the Edmund Fitzgerald parties.
Oh yeah.
I try to find that on the fucking youtube.
Hey. Yeah, it was a good comic man.
I didn't know him as a human
being. I guess you did, but no,
I didn't break a great comment. I just, I,
I know and I was just poking
fun when I said that on
stage. Of course. I know, but,
but then the point of that story is now
I'm Richard Jenny. Like people like you,
you don't fucking remember me. I opened
three like five times. Like I'm sorry,
I know you when we're doing shots
of Jaeger meister during that time.
Yeah. And maybe that memory
comes back, but you know,
a have a thing called Dunbar's number.
It's a,
it's a theory that there's only
a certain amount of numbers,
a certain amount of human beings
you can keep inside of your head.
You can only have like a friendship with
like 150 people and when it's more than
150 people and you simply
don't have storage for it,
so all the people that you meet,
I mean you're meeting hundreds of
people every fucking weekend. Your,
your brain is just overly burden and you
try to keep in touch these people and
stay friends with them.
And it's a building process because
when you first start getting any kind of
fame,
you're like,
oh you traveled from Youngstown while
I'll take you to fucking after hours.
And then, then they're, they
think they're your friends,
but then you get more fans.
So there there's a value to them because
their fans and you've never had that,
which is a shitty thing to say,
but it's the truth.
Then you get more fans and you're like,
all right,
I'm not taking you to fucking
breakfast. They were done. I see it.
Cause now I have actual fan base and
then you have too many fans and then you
don't even understand why they like you
because you hate yourself. And then, uh,
oh sorry, go to Douglas.
You don't hate yourself. No, no. I was
trying to bring that to an absurd place,
but the, you can't be friends
with your fans on some level.
It's a tricky thing when your fans,
especially,
you got a bunch of fucking psychos
fallen, you know, like I, there's,
I am not a forum suicide,
a suicide letter I
going to pose and really
we got a 4th of July where and w I had my
lawyer of fucking fact check it and it,
it's a real suicide. Yeah. He's to kill
themselves and send a letter to you. Yeah,
they sent us letters. Read. I
wanted to see it before, you know,
it was nice.
It was my friend.
Is it a picture of 4th of
July party at the house?
So I get this fan mail. I always put
my address on the fucking website.
Hey steel stuff. Hey today it's
Friday, right? Whatever it is. Tuesday,
steal something from work right now.
Podcast listeners steal
something from work.
It doesn't have to have any
value to some piece of shit.
Take your fucking coworkers picture of
their knees of their desk and mail it on
the company dime right now to
Bingo at two 12 van Dyke Street,
like Dick Van Dyke to 12
van Dyke. Bisbee, Arizona,
eight five six oh three so I put this,
I'll do this every now and then on radio
or on my Facebook just because bingos
retarded and she never understands
why all these packages are showing up.
Post it notes. Okay. Some
guys sent his his phone,
I don't know if it's Fedex
or ups or the guy wrote,
he said this is my last day on the job,
so I'm going to send it.
He sent us scanner. That's so like
obsolete. They can't replace them.
There it goes. So it has value and
it was quitting his job anyway,
so he sent something ups or
Fedex on their dime as a fuck you
Jesus Christ. That's a fucking funny.
So what do you do with all this stuff?
How much, what do you have
stored? Oh, we haven't done,
it's usually nothing of value.
I don't like I fucking ups scanner.
I drop everything at the thrift store.
I think most people's like tee
shirts that you get from, oh,
so you just take him to mean commerce.
My t shirt,
a company and you go on
a tee shirt companies.
Have you noticed how many
tee-shirt companies there are?
Everybody has a chance to teacher,
especially in the MMA world. That's,
I really noticed it.
Sell it to fucking the MMA world.
Cause guys with fucking beer guts.
Don't wear a tee shirts. I wear layers.
Do you fuck with your clothes off?
I don't fuck anymore done.
You're just lost all,
what was the last time you tapped?
What prob occasionally you do
narcotics and they go, Oh hey, yeah,
I have a sex drive. And
then you've, so yeah,
probably a Portland
once a year, but it wasn't like we'd
just start laughing in the middle ages.
This is so ridiculous. Wow. It's,
it's just, yeah, it's such a nonevent.
It feels fucking trivial. What
does that like? That's a weird,
weird feeling.
What does I like?
It's like a, if you just didn't,
you weren't hungry anymore.
You want to eat no good.
But it's funny how many people their
lives are defined by that lost in that
passion and how important it is for them.
Well,
you do see where like my comedy
is fucking slouched since then,
but you realize that you,
you boil it all down to what was the root
cause of all this desire was pussy and
then, yeah, and then you get,
and then you fucking blow a load
on her tits and you go, hmm,
isn't there a better
way to say I like you?
Like isn't there something that's
not, if she likes it, yeah,
she likes it and you like it.
It's pretty nature's fuck job where now
you can think pass nature where you go,
all right, I see what nature does, but
nature's fucked. Do you just hire you?
Where are you going to look at the
actual fucking planet earth and go,
you fucked up.
I know it's a pump has attitude,
but I guess to say that nature
is fucked and we're right.
Well, we are natural. We have logic.
We're, we're natural too, man.
That's one thing that
people don't consider.
I think that everything we do is
ultimately very natural. Natural.
The fucking the chemicals you're
promoting or natural cause it came from
somewhere in the earth. No fucking
aliens, substances. Everything is natural.
Even chemicals. It's true. Yeah. I
think behavior is as well. I think uh,
the,
the people are so fucked up because
our organism is designed to promote a
purpose and that purpose seems
to be technologically related.
It seems to be about Baz
purposes to get me a cocktail.
Little Lady. I'll take one too.
Fellow do me another one of those.
I'll take one of your items. Take
one of your diet. Fucking off brands.
Seven ups. You went to food clubs,
special food clubs. Seven like keep dying.
I keep diet for the porn stars.
That's what he said.
But he's got like some fucking offbrand.
Sam's Cola.
He told me he keeps energy
drinks for the porn stars.
They don't want an energy drink. Can I
get an energy drink? Oh No, actually no.
You have Vitaly vodka.
I drank a red bull and vodka.
I tried to get rid of that
fucking Yeager meister burden.
Just saying he agar meister on stage.
You feel like I'm fucking,
I'm 44 year old man
saying Yeager my Easter.
Is that a bad thing? Just
feeling some point, you know
at some point where you go,
I'm too old to do this. You've
had those moments. Yeah,
when you're doing shots but somehow or
another whiskey you could be 60 and still
get a shot of whiskey. You're doing
Jaeger bombs and you're 60 sac commander,
but any class,
but I've,
I've grown a taste for all this shit
where it like I was all the beer that I
like is just shit horrible corporate
beer and I watched football too.
So what? Embrace it. But no, the, the,
the fact that you see all the ads are
geared towards the dumbest people alive
and you go,
I like your product.
Why do you make me feel like an asshole
for fucking having a giant ad campaign
saying that the fucking label tells
me when it's cold because I don't have
fucking temperature. It's,
but that's what I like. Shit,
enjoy shit. I'm, I'm,
I'm, I'm at terms with it.
I just hate when it's marketed towards me.
I know it's talking about when
it treats you like you're dumb,
but there's a lot of shit. That's
cool. You know I like muscle cars.
I know they're stupid. I know that
dumb. I don't care. I like, I like,
I have a Shelby Mustang. I liked the way
it sounds. I, when I hit the gas, he goes,
mom,
I'm very aware that we're on a planet
and this planet is a part of a galaxy and
this galaxy,
I'm enjoying this fucking Mustang.
You know one I didn't ask to be here.
Exactly. Yeah, exactly. Fuck you and your,
I didn't sue my mother.
She's the one who had the fucking gall
to create life without its consent. Yeah.
That's my attitude towards anybody that
tells you that you're supposed to be
really involved in our political system.
Hey,
and we're born into a fucking system
that we have no control over and it's
absolutely completely fucked.
It's really,
you want me to really get involved and
invested in this? Is that really fixable?
Yeah, no, you make your own fucking
government. It's what the Amish do.
It's what gangs do.
You make your own fucking reality,
but then the federal government is always
the big daddy looking over the whole
time that you learn to avoid the
same way you avoid fucking scorpions.
Arizona shake out my
shit before I put it on.
How often he gets scorpions.
Well, not often enough,
but if it's been sitting there for awhile,
you shake it out cause you
know your environment. Yeah,
exactly. The point is, yeah,
the same way you avoid every
other fucking obstacle.
You would just avoid the government.
You vote for Ron Paul and it makes you
feel good and it's nothing to do on a
Tuesday anyway and it makes it
theirs can't start a compound now.
They don't let you do that. Can't
do that. Don't call it a compound.
That's the thing is people
can have guns in Hong Kong.
The church should be fucking like,
Ooh,
I'm going to get on fucking radio until
everyone's coming to my copout Waco.
You know what? Just fucking shut up.
Go down and fucking property's cheap.
And Texas. You get a whole
compound and just say, Hey,
do you think you'll ever mind
fucking proselytize? Yeah,
you can get plenty of pussy just running
it that way. Yeah. You know she crazy.
Everyone that's in a fucking criminal
element has to be so like they take it too
far. Yeah. What gets him to the
party ultimately drowns them.
They drown in their own desire to occupy.
Wall Street would dress up like Wall
Street, so there were indecipherable.
It's a fucking thrift store.
You got to cut your hair.
It's a lot of dudes with dreadlocks.
Exactly. So commit yourself to the cause.
You know what? That's fucking
hell. That's why I love anonymous.
Like if they fucking sold
merge, I'd buy, I buy a shirt.
I was thinking Brian should
do a guy Fawkes mask day.
We wear the mask fucking anonymous.
Like people like that are
in there doing something.
They're fucking with the system.
Wiki leaks is fucking with this
system and you're fucking g,
you're going to camp. You're going to walk
for a cure is what you're going to do.
What they are little dude
is there represents a giant
numbers. Who Do we need?
Soldiers. You need a non like you
need leaders down fucking. Yeah,
but the problem is they go after leaders.
And the beautiful thing about this whole
occupy Wall Street thing is there's no
leaders. That's the beautiful thing about
it. But there's no, there's no guidance,
there's no guide leaders.
There's a pretty cohesive message.
The point it could be done
if you like. Yes. Men. The style,
like there's so many that you
see that fucking, it's like,
it's like a Dane Cook audience.
Without a comic we you
see that fucking need for,
you could turn this force into something
and they're such fucking dimwits like
any movement,
most of the populace is going to be
a fucking dimwit and they need to,
well,
you know,
I mean if you want to go back and read
the conspiracy theories of the 60s and
the 70s that the idea was that they were
engineering our civilization to be the
stupid and that they were engineering
the poor neighborhoods that have shit
education and keeping the,
the priorities of education at a minimum
so that they can continue to run people.
Because most people are too fucking
stupid to realize what's going on.
As long as they can keep
this charade going. Yes.
That's why it's all falling apart.
It's because the Internet now as allowed
pretty much everybody to see what's
really happening in the world.
See where the real numbers are
going for what Alex Jones sees.
He sees something you can't even
z on the Internet.
The lesson can I 91st unless you buy gold,
ladies and gentlemen.
Right now,
they have baskets out in the desert
where they're looking to put your goal
setting or McCain, you
aren't disgraced, sir.
I remember when we were talking about
occupy all day and I said something silly
like about how I think
they should move to the uh,
the trees and like make an easy
walk village, I guess. Exactly.
That's exactly what happened before
the pocket was saying that the God,
that guy's a guy from fear factor. Oh
yes. Yeah. Oh, he's on fear factors.
His name is Shane. That's crazy. He was on
fear factor with his check. So that's a,
they're creating all confused.
That's ridiculous. Yeah. It's a very
strange thing, man. It's a weird movement.
There's all these people camped
out, man, and a lot of them,
this is where the foot they need,
why do you need a fucking movement?
That's what nay. I'm Stan hope
you don't need a fucking route.
But to me this is an exciting time.
This is really interesting.
I don't know what's happening,
but to me I see, oh,
these numbers of people moving and
these numbers of people protesting or
unprecedented.
We've never had a public display of how
fucking pissed people are like this.
A public display of how many people are
saying this is in snow. It's insane.
It's amazing. I know it. It needs
to be corralled, but it's going to,
it's going to eventually,
first of all,
the real unfortunate aspect of
it at all is that they're trying,
as hard as the Caesar's will says,
his pizza of occupy Wall Street brought
to you by all of the most unfortunate
and aspect of it is that
if it keeps growing,
they're going to keep pushing it back and
eventually something's going to break.
You know, and they're going
to push the boat. But I mean,
we've already had people getting hurt,
people getting hit with tear gas canisters
and their fucking face flash grenades.
We've already had a lot of that shit
happen. But if it keeps growing,
it's going to keep and
they're going to have to push
back. I mean it's, it's, it's
almost inevitable. But what I,
so what happens then? That's, it becomes
a real problem. Where does it go?
No one's explained to me
what the fucking fight is.
The fight is that the system's fuck.
The fight is that people
didn't want all these bailouts.
They don't think that all that is such
a broad thing. It's absolutely broad.
That's what we've known for years.
You're right,
because do general general ignorant
reaction or not, not ignorant. Um,
the mob action is ignorant. The reaction
it is, I don't want to say ignorant,
but what it is is it's,
it's a,
it's an unfocused anger with a good
percentage of the people who have a clear
idea. What's the problem? Well,
there's a lot of them that
absolutely running around,
like from a completely
military point of view. Yes.
You need a bunch of stupid people who
don't really know what's going on. Well,
y'all fortunately they get
interviewed by the press.
You need fucking numbers and most of the
populace is dumb as shit. You fucking,
you have to get numbers. Not
only that, there's also, um,
a real tactic of agent provocateurs where
there's cops that I know that's up and
go in and start shit and then arrested.
Why don't they do the fucking same thing?
Bag,
dress,
dress like a cop without going
to jail without the insignia.
Yeah.
Put on fucking riot gear.
Why are you sitting out there or I'm
a week hippie dress up like a fucking
raider fan. Johnny fucking
Mad Max Element. Darth Vader.
Yeah. Be as intimidating as that.
More intimidating than the cops. Yeah.
Put on the attire of a guy.
Really?
I just write her for fucking occupy Wall
Street and not against them. I'm not,
I don't know what they're for.
Yeah,
the system's fucked and I'm glad that
you're out there doing something.
I just want to fucking write some ideas
for you rather than make it so fucking
obvious. I'm a hippie. Well,
don't you think that's just inevitable
whenever you have any sort of a gathering,
that's why I want to join.
I'd rather be gonna do.
You're gonna kick the people that suck.
I don't like comedy and go out and go
hair and here's a better sign. Yeah,
we are the 99% all right, everyone else
has that sign. I want to fucking help.
Let's make this funnier,
funnier revolution.
Like how is that going to help you get
rid of all the retards? How's that?
Doesn't, there's no way to get rid of the
retards. There's no way to an educator.
You can fucking educate your kids.
You have two kids now and you can pretend
like you're going to have an influence
on their life, but you can have
an influence on my life for sure.
When you're not going to, yeah, they're
not going to run the whole thing.
It's an independent human being.
Fucking Patton.
Oswald had the great bit about how kids
always rebel against their parents.
So I'm going to be the worst parent in
the world and we're going to have Phil
Collins, no jacket required
framed on the mantle piece.
So my kids turned out cool.
That's funny.
Yeah, it's a weird idea. You know,
trying to figure out what way
to push and pull your kids.
You see them reacting to you though. So
that's the strangest thing. You see them,
you know,
like getting upset that you telling
them that they can't do something and so
they, they rebound the other way.
You know, you could see that,
that pattern development really early
where a lot of us, you know, I mean,
I don't know how you were raised,
but I met your mom.
You're the only friend I have that
I'd don't dismiss once they have kids
because you have kids like a fucking,
like a terrarium project.
When I'm on a fucking control the growth,
I'm going to monitor it.
You're not a parent.
I'm a parent.
I mean I can just know you are by
enjoy same way. You've never been like,
we never met your girlfriend.
I like, I'm going the, well,
I guess most of us had the guy that
brings up girl. Nope. Girlfriend.
My whole personal life is a,
it's almost like your friends or TMZ.
I know.
I'm going to keep everything private.
La, he know me as well as most people.
Well that was, I never met.
Exactly. Exactly. Jessica. Yeah.
Tone. Don't say names. Oh Shit.
Sorry. It's too little. Fuck.
All right, well we haven't talked
in a while. It's all right.
She doesn't go by her married name.
Um, yeah, sorry. Yeah, no, I tell
people everything. I just don't,
I don't tell the Internet everything.
You and I have a never
comedy, friendship, you know,
but yet don't, no, no, no, no.
And you're just comedy life.
Like I, when you said, hey, I'll come into
the UFC and I go, I don't like that man.
There's a lot of dudes that the integrate
these girls that they're dating into
their fucking comedy life and they bring
him everywhere and you know the problem
with that change their personality,
which I've seen since then. It's weird.
It gets weird, you know, I, I've seen
it. I mean, it's nothing wrong. I mean,
you can take your chicken anywhere.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but I don't think you should all,
you should always do things together.
I think there's nothing wrong
with having really separate lives.
Bingo is the only thing is fucking
friend in the world. Watch.
It works for you guys. Yeah. It's
like whatever works, you know,
for what me has always worked is you
got to separate church and state for W.
Yeah. I know. That's always been, there's
always been kind of a border, but no,
it's never ever border, dude. No.
It's nothing you introduced to into and
you're just so alien from like my shit,
if that's what you mean. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm getting back, coming back. I'm
good. Gonna come back. You feeling it?
Do you want an energy drink to push
you over the title? No, I'm good.
I have a cocktail. I fee. I
just, you're centering. Yeah.
My fucking head has been
in so many places when you,
when you're just like,
oh, what's a microphone?
And it was just fucking high shit.
All right.
You understand what a microphone is and
I'm not really baffled anymore by the
fact that we can talk to
a million people of CBE.
Zick we're all in the same room.
I think it's amazing how well
you've actually held it together.
I could ever podcast showrooming
he did an amazing job.
This, um, occupy Wall Street thing.
This is why I pulled this article up
cause I knew we were going to talk about
this. This is, uh, the National
Defense Authorization Act.
This is what I was talking about earlier,
where they're,
they're literally going to define the
US homeland as a battlefield and make us
citizens subject to military apprehension
and detainment for life without access
to a trial or attorney. This
is amazing. I mean, this is,
there's something that they've crafted.
This is another high thing,
but you're acting like law matters. No,
I'm not, but I'm acting like this is,
I mean it's actually cops beat you
every fucking day. What? Oh, it's in,
but it's against the constitution.
Like no one cares that such a,
but they do care. I mean, people
were really freaking out about that.
If you're one guy that occasionally
brings something to a supreme court every
four years and they go, you
were right, you were fucked.
And then he gets nothing out
of the battle. But in your
general day, you, sorry.
Well,
this is what this is,
is trying to turn the US into a place
where they can have the military patrol
things. So the military, which control
things like occupy Wall Street there,
they're preparing for civil unrest and
they're preparing to do it legally.
And what they're preparing to do is to
make the United States a battleground so
that when you are in a situation
like occupy Wall Street,
you're literally like an enemy combatant.
But they've been doing that for
10 years or putting it on paper.
And that's what's really crazy.
And they're trying,
there's so blatant about it that
they're literally putting this on paper.
You know,
they're,
they're trying to pass this through and
people are fucking freaking out about it,
man. Well that's good. Yeah. Finally.
But it's still amazing that this is
something that they're so fucking stupid.
These people live in a different age.
They live in an age of the media
reporting things, you know,
and when these things get out on the
Internet and CNN is not covering it and
Washington Times isn't covering it,
but you can get it on your fucking
computer and go, what is this shit?
Is this real? And then you make some
phone calls and you'll find out it is.
And everybody freaks the fuck out.
And,
and you know he's asked her
life miserable like scares me,
scares me, scares me. They
shouldn't be allowed to do that.
They shouldn't be allowed to bring,
look,
there's a reason why people are
freaking out and these people need to be
addressed. They need, you need to
figure out how to deal with that.
And the way to deal with
it isn't a fucking tank.
And it says in Tiananmen Square,
there's supposed to be the United
States and at the end of the day change
without like drastic. Why is that? But
it isn't. They were internet drastic.
The Internet is the most drastic fuck.
Nothing can ever be introduced
to a society ever. People have,
they have to pay their fucking mortgage.
You,
you see people that are like rolling their
own cigarettes and if they don't give
a fuck about some law passing,
they're trying to fucking feed fat kids.
So when everyone's down,
it was like, what, when?
That's how revolutions there is no
fucking revolution of the middle class is.
It was actually when the middle class
rose up and said, I think you're right.
In a certain sense,
and I think it has your cynical,
they're cynical viewpoint is
pragmatical is, I mean it's normal.
It's based on data, based on
history. You're absolutely right,
but it's not based on the best that
people are capable of the best to keep
people are capable of.
They're capable of much more than that.
It's just that we can't pull it off on
a mass scale. We're just not good at it,
but we were capable of it.
We're more than capable of pretty
fucking awesome behavior on an individual
basis.
And then the key is trying to figure out
how that can be relayed to the entire
population as an ethic.
And the only way that's going to ever
work is if people feel like the system
that they operate under is fair
and right now they clearly don't.
Right now that people feel like they
look at all the money that's going into
these CEOs that have been fucking what
he looks at that they do, they do.
They look at the numbers, they
can help it. That's your fan base.
Don't ever confuse your fan base
with what lives in the fucking world,
in the dark houses and the fuck. You're
right. You're right. 66 you're right.
For the most part,
they don't ever think about which
plenty of people that do though.
The people that are informed of that
should be the ones that you're paying
attention to,
right?
Water Cooler talk where they've fucking
mimic bumper stickers. Yes. That,
but they have no idea what a fucking
CEO is or how it affects their,
you're absolutely right.
One of fucking get Velveeta cheese for
their fucking kid and if it's a dollar
off, they're happy and they're
not even poor. You're right.
That's a real question though, is why
are they liked that? And the question is,
are they like that because
of nature or nurture.
And they liked that because they grew
up in this fucked up society where,
you know,
in the fifties and sixties or whatever
the fuck time they were developing,
there was no information. Everybody was
horse shit. Everybody was, you know, you,
you, you act like information
is something that people want.
We are in a five that
you wanted it or not.
There's enough people that want it
that are moving things. Yeah, no,
but were we live in a very insular,
we think,
oh you have fucking 3 million listeners,
but they just want to hear
fist fuck jokes. Most of them.
That's one thing like Facebook has made
me realize how many times people laugh
for the wrong reasons because they comment
about it and lose all respect for a
dude when you see a legit lol. Uh, yeah.
But it so easy is respect for someone.
I try not to.
So I try to be open minded about, I was
talking about earlier though, I do LLS,
I do happy faces. I just don't care.
Like, I think it's funny as a joke.
Yeah. Well you, when you do lol to me,
I actually do think it's funny
because I know it's not a real lol.
It's like you're making fun of
the fact that you're saying lol.
You're going to just silly joke this
three times gone, right? Yeah. Hey it
calm day that you are around four and hey,
let me be the wacky neighbor.
That's what your friends would say and
then then they said it too much and
you're like, all right,
that's such a cliche.
Let me be your wacky neighbor that now
it's a cliche of when it wasn't cliches.
Oh, it's funny. Again, maybe your
wacky neighbor on your podcast,
so that's true. Yeah.
Yeah. Like refried beans,
lol, lol, stop. Why do
I have to my God damn
ugly head everywhere I look,
it's just what it looks like.
You got to just look at me. Focus
on the magic. He looked very good.
You look very healthy.
Keep going into Diniro though.
You actually look really
healthy this time. You look
really, you look really good.
It's out in the sun. My house was on the
fucking women's group is be home tour.
So I had to be out the women's group.
Busy home tour. What does that actually,
I think it was like nick soon.
I had to leave him.
I'm sorry I can't call you back right now,
but
I haven't. I called someone
with an excuse where I go, I,
I'm ashamed to admit it has something
to do with the whip Bisbee women's club.
Oh that's hilarious. So they would do
it like a tour of the homes in the area.
They won't do it every year they do a
Bisbee home tour cause there's a lot of
weird houses there.
So we,
after 29 years in a town of
6,000 they were out of ideas.
So they came to us because we paint
our rocks. Weird Duck. What do you do?
You paint your rocks weird. You, I'll
try it again. All right here. Jack,
have you done anything lately?
Five, five 40 pranks. You know what,
it was the awesome, but Austin was
just fucking wore off on me. Dude.
I got affected by Brian.
Red Band was when you would do those a
pedophile baiting's did you put those out
in a book? Yeah, I put him out in a book,
but the title of the book
is a fun with pedophiles,
which I had never even
considered because you know,
I'm the fucking last guy to know.
Even thinking about technology.
Sorry, just this is another
reason I don't smoke, but
yeah, that's why you have
a cigarette in your hand.
I never thought that people wouldn't
want to punch pedophiles into a search
engine. I don't know what a search
engine, you don't want that.
And that's the name of the book I get.
Can you rerelease it was another hood.
Just call it beating is. Yeah. The best
debating is the subtitle. Oh, okay.
Yeah. But Fun with pedophiles. That
is a problem. Yeah, this is fucking,
you gotta be real careful about that
these days. That probably brings up some,
there's like some crazy search
engine database with the FBI, right?
Yeah. Fun with pedophiles.
I love the cover.
It's so nice.
Ballsy.
And if the best positive
reviews to look at that. Yeah.
So folks go get that book
because it is fucking hilarious.
Cause I remember when a lot of title,
the only stuff I've ever done that I go
back and I laugh my balls off at my own
stuff. It was really good comedy. I
hate it. I can't listen to an old album,
a new album. Fun what? Pedophiles.
I read and I fucking laugh like someone
else wrote it. Well that was uh, those,
those baiting days. Is
that still up? What, what,
what it means it's archived active,
but you can read all their shit. So good
stuff. So much good stuff. Wicked funny.
There's a guy that
called don't even reply.
Com that fucks with craigslist people.
But he only updates it like
every fucking three months.
You come back from Europe and you're like,
Oh,
don't even reply the have because he's
so good. It's wicked funny. Wow. So get,
yeah, go. You guys are bored. Go to,
don't even reply.com and say do some more
shit is out of Philly, I think. Yeah.
Do you, uh, do you remember when
the Jerky boys weren't famous?
Remember when it was like a tape
that would go round tapes like a,
they're making a documentary out of a,
what do you shut up? Little Man. Yeah.
Yeah. Red Red Bar. Is that
what it is? The Red Bar was,
that's what most is lack is
based on in the Simpsons.
The toolbar to the right,
right.
They based most is lack
on the two bar tapes.
Alcoholic.
That was the famous two bar.
Does this out alcoholic and then
he finally catch on and he'd go,
Yep, mother, fuck ICAK Sockeye
fucking, I'll carry out.
Find your mother fucking,
yeah, the two bar tapes. Yeah.
That guy was hilarious. That's
what I was thinking. Oh,
Winnebago man is a documentary
based on those days,
which is fantastic when a big old man
is based on this guy who was a Winnebago
salesman who would just,
he would do these videos where he was
doing a commercial and then in he would
fuck up the take and they played
all the outtakes. When you fuck up,
we'd start squaring you motherfucker. You
mother was con. It would just get crazy.
Awesome. But yeah, the feel good story.
At the end like you don't expect it to
go well and it was actually a documentary
where at the end you're like, ah, I
fucking feel really good about myself.
It was because the guy was like, he was
fucking a horrible functional. Okay,
sure. On privacy. I don't even,
what the fuck I'm reading.
I'll know what the fuck the real
dialogue is. What the fuck is this thing?
All of the windshield.
Perfect fuck sake. Oh fuck.
What the fuck did I say that
in Psalm for shit did it.
Trying to give these guys
everything they can get to me.
Not sounds like a perfectionist.
No. What the fuck I'm saying?
Let's just get mad at himself.
We suppose we opened
gotta do it again right now.
I feel like those guys that were, ah,
we knew this one. They were garage band.
Oh fuck.
Let's, he's just trying to do a good
time when he keeps fucking it up.
Donnie, do me a favor. Will you please?
Will you do me a kindness? Yeah.
I think I don't want
you walking in and out.
I don't dare make any difference to me
at this juncture. Thank you very much.
Appreciate that Tony.
Don't slam the fucking door
no more.
Okay.
You remember that video is because of
this video that went around back in the
day when people just passed
off tapes. Yeah. Big giant VHS.
Dave, you gotta check this out. I remember
those very world pooping on a deed.
Yeah, I would a, I had
a friend from Austin,
he used to give me these fucking
mix tapes that he would make you.
I just got rid of him recently cause I
had already seen the images a hundred
times but his videos would be all the
weirdest shit that he ever found and he
would splice them together. It was
like an art form for him. Yeah.
Used to do that all the time.
I [inaudible] if you Google
search or Red Band Java lamps,
I have a few of them like that where
I just put like it was right when the
Internet video is becoming big.
Like the crazy shit.
Like you know a woman found inside
of an alligator, you know, type shit.
And it was like just spliced and I
put it with her like trippy music.
Wow. That's in a while. That used to
be the Internet was just like, Oh,
a human internet. Like you'd have
to hand someone the videotape.
Like that's how it goes.
I mean,
he could transfer that in that idea as
a virus or as an organism could transfer
all over the place from person to
person and even be like duplicated.
Even though it gets really fucking
grainy when it gets like third and fourth
generation. But that's what you had to do.
That's how you got things out, you know?
And you, you, you saw
Barnyard Betty, right?
Did you ever see barnyard bending
when you were a kid? No. No. Really?
I might've seen it, but I don't
know. It wasn't titled Wild Optin.
Rowdy was the guy that
turned me as a young comic.
There's a guy named captain rowdy,
I remember that guy's name. Yeah.
He was a anywhere like leather jackets
and shit, leather chaps and Mohawk.
And there's a lot of dudes like that.
It had like a fucking whole thing.
But they had,
he had a huge following in the south west,
not including California,
uh, but lovely. Lubbock,
Lubbock, Texas, and take me on
the road. And he was, he like,
he's a, he's still, if he's,
he would be in my death pool.
If he had a Wikipedia page. It doesn't
have to look at peanut butter days.
He's going to die. He like calls me
every couple months. Like he's fucked.
It's a long story.
I want to do a documentary about all the
80s comics and thought they had it made.
We were making five grand a week. You
didn't even have to have jokes. And they,
but they banked their light and you've,
you know,
some of the relics of that and do the,
do you ever see the documentary
beyond the mat, beyond the mat?
What does it say about wrestling and it
has it like Jake the snake Roberts and
he's all fucking plan and some armory
in Carney Nebraska and smoking crack and
Whoa. And then old guys that
are still trying to do it,
their knees are falling apart like fucking
but there's still in it and then guys
trying out for it,
they get it.
So it's a whole balance of this whole
wrestling seem like new guy, old guy.
And I've had folks, I would love to do
a documentary like that about comedy.
The guys that thought
they fucking had a ride.
If there's a bunch of guys that Vic
Dunlop was like a guy that I like when I
thought of this idea,
captain rowdy is such a
fucking magnificent story.
Do you think those guys,
I mean some of them are
still working right,
so they're just out there just so there's
guys that made it to the guys to get a
perspective
of the guy that is fucking dying and lost
his legs to diabetes and just did coke
down of lawyers playing fucking
Biloxi, Mississippi, Mr Saturday night.
You know those guys. Right, right, right.
That it would just be a beautiful
fucking documentary to watch. Oh,
could be interesting.
They're just guys just wrote it to the
wheels fell off and there's guys that are
still doing triple gigs in their sixties
but they're happy with it. There's some,
some are happening. Yeah. Yeah.
When I was living in Boston,
there was a lot of guys won't accept
when people are happy with things that
they've built some kind
of fake value system on.
If you don't, well you're not
there so you can't be happy. No,
I'm actually fucking wicked happy
living in a small town with, yeah. Yeah.
I didn't move there to
fucking make it big stupid.
Doug, do you remember the point
when we first met? Uh, I came,
I forgot Brian's here and I like talking.
I came to Ohio University and I,
it was like I recorded you and it,
was that still on Youtube? Yeah,
it was a walked like 600 people.
They fucking,
they billed me as I,
I still and I,
it was that tour if not that night as the
last time I can remember doing a shows
sober and I remember like Ed Helms was
on the fucking bill and Flan again.
Finnegan yet again fitting in.
Yeah.
Oh somehow I fucking those the
last time you did a show sober
last I can remember it was,
it was parents like doing shows sober.
I'm not by myself amusing
and fucking sober.
It was parents of the
future weekend though.
They billed it as like a family friendly
show and but it was parents weekend
this weekend.
Family friendly is listed in the program
and there's not a lot of fucking on
campus options for entertainment.
It's not a town.
He said fucking campus what your parents
and under fucking fun for all the
family is the comedy central
presents to her with Doug Larkin.
Everyone else that they find it fine
and then I like your kid's going to get
fucked here.
Like people in the video that like
people were like yelling like you get off
stage, you know? I mean
this is high this year.
Like some angry dad right
beside where he's filming. Yeah.
Are you finding this? I know it's on
you. You were watching it right now here.
Right here.
This is a whole set.
No,
it's just pieces of your set and then
it goes to the part where the guy starts
yelling. People are like, Dario,
this audio is way too bad.
Then the guy starts screaming at that.
You could hear that.
Yup.
He's talking about buff fucking read.
Doris would never have these
kinds of delays. Just say
yeah he wouldn't,
but that's the charm part of the charm
is the fact that this fucking glitches in
the matrix.
Here it comes right here
are you barely can understand what
you're saying. Unfortunately. I know.
I wish he could if he
get queued up to though.
Here we go.
He's full of shit and anyone crazy enough
to listen to that mother fuckers who
is he's,
that's what he's,
but the whole time there's just people
standing up and just like filing out
because this was like the first,
I think if this was like the first
weekend with like all the new students,
you know, were they, there was a
third of the crowded a theater. Yeah.
It was so weird. Wow. That's an
uncomfortable feeling. Oh yeah.
People always get angry and I,
there's this uncomfortable feelings like,
do you do like we did those fucking music
festivals knowing I was going to get
fucking trashed and music
festivals leads and reading.
When did you do this? This is the
reason. It's like two, three years ago.
What happened? It's just that
there's no way I'm going to fight.
These are people that bought
tickets for three days.
They didn't buy tickets to you or comedy.
Is it tense and I'm not, I'm
not a guy that's, I'm not
fucking Hedberg where I go.
There's another joke.
I have a guy that I'm like this,
I'm a fucking two hour podcast of me
stuttering and looking for a cigarette and
then yelling about something when it
strikes me it's not going to work at a
music festival.
They were fucking just audibly booing
me just cause I'm boring to them.
Well you've still got your own
crowd now. I know, but it's,
they know what you're doing and they
want to see it and a person who doesn't
know you want to try to get them in
there like you're not designed to work.
Like when you're coming up your act
as sort of designed to work on as many
people as possible.
You try to sort of maximize it.
I wouldn't now I now I'm defining them.
Actually I'm turning down fans at this
point. But then yeah, a waiting list.
It's like a lambo field.
I can only have this many fans.
Sorry. Stand on the porch.
Like fight club for three days.
You must get a lot of weird
motherfucker said come visit you.
You're so Denise throwing all the fucking
time. I don't know what's going on.
I'm still fucking high as shit.
And indeed,
when I first moved to La, Doug was the
first person that like I was friends with.
I think, uh, like it like,
well you obviously Joe,
but like d like Doug would like call me
up and just be like, hey man, I'm bored.
You want to go make some shit about you?
You only sell only this stuff you can
say behind your back because you're very
angry and it talks shit. No, no,
I'm saying it was always fun to
talk shit behind Joe's back. Oh,
well we made it used to
make these, so I'm saying, I
probably talked a lot of shit
about Joe to you. Oh, okay.
Well we used to make these videos because
he got mad at Verizon Dsl because he
had DSL at the time. And so we were
like, hey, let's go to the thrift stores.
He would go to the thrift store
and we buy like terrorists outfits.
And then we've made these, we made these
videos, he made these videos and I said,
Marlin, I'm to all the, the,
the Verizon corporate office number
after that guy had been beheaded.
So it will be like, I was even afraid to
put these up. Like I remember being like,
all right, you could get too much
shit, dude. This is dangerous.
You've got Aaron writing. What
does that writing? Yeah, no,
after everyone was like,
oh, he's not really Arabic.
Right?
You told me my service would
be taught and it's been a week.
And by the way,
that's Doug on both sides.
That was through a store,
a Muslim baby backward before the
Muslims ward tags off their burgers.
Hey, why don't we just play the fucking
man show? Hit him in the head with a pen.
Go ahead. Right. The second day
is, let's not, let's, let's stop.
Let's stop right here. But yeah,
I just stopped the whole podcast.
I think we've done enough.
This podcast has been like fucking,
what has it been like two and a half hours
long. Two hours. 20 minutes. Oh Shit.
So at some point you're right.
At some point we're right. Well,
the first 20 minutes, I'm like,
we've been here for
like four hours. No, no.
It's only six o'clock we're still
good. We're still rolling now. Yeah,
that they'll have cocktails since
you're good. Do you want to keep going?
Good for the show. I want to keep
going. Another like 1520 minutes. Oh,
I'll fucking talk. As long as people
were putting in work on the fucking John,
I want to dig another 20 minutes
and then call it a night. Yeah.
People aren't getting, you can turn it
off at whatever point. Yes. That's a good,
good piece of advice.
You don't want to see me get hit in
the head with a fucking good dude.
It goes long.
It's not like the fucking Bray at Improv
where they're paying for parking or
listening to a podcast. You're taking a
shit right now. It goes a little too long.
If it goes too long,
just make it fucking three parts.
You're the director asshole.
One minute longer.
Three part by hitting new
is one minute long. Yeah.
You quit the cigarettes for a little
bit, right? Yeah. For a year. Got Fat,
started smoking again,
stayed fat.
Now I cough while I'm fat.
So you did it as sort of a dietary
measure to just no, no. I just,
I quit for a year,
like 2008
and then went to Costa Rica
and uh,
buck 25 pack at the bar
and you can smoke everywhere. You
can smoke at bars. You just figured,
fuck it just for this vacation ain't
going. I, yeah, we'll, we'll just,
just for this week and yeah.
So I've been trying to quit since 2008.
Oh Wow.
That sucks.
That must feel weird, man. That's
gotta be a very weird thing,
like connected to something, you know,
and it's not easy to escape. Right.
The worst part is every time he smokes,
I want to light one up immediately.
Like I'm like, can I just see
it? And I'm like, all right,
I got it. Like I told you,
I quit coffee recently,
but it's only been like eight days.
I can't even say I quit coffee.
I'm just seeing when it's likely it's
not drink coffee for a long time.
The third time this has happened,
but when you said fried clams
in a conversation before, right.
I just fixated on fried clams and I
made my face make the motions like I'm
listening,
but I was thinking and then you said
something about fucking Burrito's you're
hungry. No, it is just as the
third time when you say coffee,
am I fucking Bailey's coffee? And then
I'm looking around and I distract myself.
So what you're saying is I got a good
voice for advertising just every now and
then.
You mentioned a fucking thing.
I'm just saying when I look
like I'm being fake, I am.
Because you're thinking about whatever
you're like, why is Robert Deniro
saying I should have a Bailey's coffee?
Oh, Douglas. Why do you think
it? I never think Robert Deniro,
Robert to me,
I think more of a heel Julio fallacious
guy or whatever that guys love people.
Again,
I have like,
I have a fucking high
i's where this is like
came on home.
I dedicate this song.
You need a mall.
One point I thought I was getting my
elbow in the pool because the ashtray is
right here and at one point I'm like,
and I pulled away like I was going to
get all those cigarettes during the time
we do this podcast. I'm going
to like, yeah, that's it.
Like 10 gave me a whole pack.
Seven, eight, nine, nine
cigarettes. You're crazy. Smells.
It seems like so many. You got that chain
smoker. David tells two packs again.
David tells worse times to, yeah. He
goes to the doctor so he knows he's,
he has emphysema. Like I, I don't
know nothing. I don't know anything.
How many swung into the
day? Uh, not, not as many
a pack. Yeah. Pack now probably. Yeah.
There's nothing that replaces that.
Huh? You ever try cigars? I could quit.
I just fucking Nafta take time.
Quit before cigars would
make you a classic douchebag.
I was last year. Ron White, like
Ron White has this exhibit. Yeah.
He has this whole fucking,
a whole circular exemption from Ev.
Everything completely agree.
Every picture he has it,
he's under a cloud of that.
That you don't know why.
Ralphie may gut the amnesty but white
and he has this whole, Ralphie
May's a lovable guy, right? Yeah.
But Ron White on white barn,
the whole yup.
100% I did I tell you about what
he's buying jokes from. You know,
he has a lot of writers and uh,
Andy,
he has bought a couple of Andy
Andrews a bit silly and I,
when I saw him in Austin,
I go, yeah, you buy him.
Like my buddy's got a couple of his
bits in it and he said without any shame
whatsoever. Ron White says, yeah,
we buy a lot of really funny
bits from really funny comics.
And then what we do is take,
take the teeth out of them
so they're not funny anymore.
And then my audience applauds
fucking biomaterial I'm fucking selling
fucking snake oil to fucking sucker is
cause I know this ain't going to last.
So what does he waters is act down?
Is that what he's doing?
And he's just backing off.
He plays to that audience and he,
he's fuck heel toe,
his fucking Rolls Royce off the back
of his tour bus. He's like, he's like,
he's like a vanilla ice in like jokingly,
like he's like flashing all this
because he knows it's pointless.
But allies like flashy, like you'll
like drives rolls Royces rappers like,
I'm sorry this is the second time and
fucking three days where I tried to find a
fucking rapper preference
preference and [inaudible] ll cool.
Just go with Birdman. I said no, he's
love of automobiles and he's very quiet.
Birdman. Birdman. Okay. Some
rat you fucking listen to.
I don't fucking garbage.
Well when I was listening to is why
reality TV works cause everyone wants to
think they could do it too. And that's
why I rap music works because yeah,
you could do it too.
I like some rappers.
Well I like Nas to know nausea's
no really like that guy.
I know he was a small,
I think it was in a play off of like one.
I can listen to notorious Bij all
day. I love that old, that old shit.
I love his, his rap style. I think
there's, it's rhythmic. It's fun.
It's fun for me. But you don't
like to use it. It's I understand.
I understand,
but you don't like music.
But I can look at fucking
Zeplin on the wall and go.
I'm fascinated that someone
could learn to do that.
Not someone sat on a
fucking bus with a notebook.
I don't know about their fucking shit.
I would take this for almost everybody.
Seven notorious B I.
G he didn't just make Shit Ryan.
He made Shit Ryan with
flow and a rhythm to it.
That was fun. It'd be like it was, it was
fun to listen to. I'll never, you know,
that guy was an artist.
He was a fucking artist and what he
did was very difficult to do. It's,
it's very difficult to duplicate. There's
a bunch of guys that are a rap artists.
Listen, I am like Cypress Hill
reaching from the most uneducated.
I'm just saying things with confidence.
I know nothing about
music doesn't interest me.
I'm like the last guy and that's why I
always say I hate music is because I'm
such a comedy snob that I
know of. Someone said, Oh,
who do you like Jeff Dunham and peanut?
And I immediately hate you
because you said that like,
I have a bias against you and I know that
I'm that much of a pedestrian when it
comes to music. So if I go, yeah,
I fucking Love The counting crows,
I now I have to fucking,
there's no apology, which is
an apology when you say, Oh,
I'm not even apologizing for
liking matchbox 20 like whatever.
What is the the,
I mean for most people,
like music is sort of a source of
pleasure. It's like a, you know,
it's fun to listen to.
It's motivating.
What is it about it that
you think it's just,
is it interferes with
the noise in your head?
I always knew,
I found it summed up succinctly in a
book that I will now miss quote and ruin,
but Dow is the fucking guy,
the drunkard guy.
He was a drunkard in England. Dues.
I always want to say Allister,
but it's not Allister mcallister fucking,
I can't remember his name.
He summed up how pop music ruined the
pub culture in England because when they
introduced the Juke box that played over
the conversation that you were there to
have,
you go to the fucking bar to talk and
now someone introduced music where either
you want to listen to the music or you
want to have the conversation but out.
And that's why I've always hated music.
It's something that I want to enjoy.
Like if I'm really high and I have 400
songs from my life that I can remember
that I like, they're on an iPod.
If I need music, I go to it.
Like people go to comedy
clubs once a year. I hear Ya.
Do you find that, did you use to make
music is something that you just who,
oh I've music, it's just, but
it's a part time thing to me.
Like most people, comedy's a part
time thing. Do us, that's life.
Fucking listening and words and
I fucking love music and
I get inspired by it.
I love what I'm working out
in love listening to it.
I love listening to what I'm driving.
You know? I love listening to it.
Sometimes when I'm just thinking how
much hit it encapsulates a mood for me.
I just appreciate the art.
I don't know how to do it.
I don't know anything about music.
I can't sing.
I don't know how to play a
fucking single instrument. So my,
my interest of it is like purely
as a, just a fan. Believe me,
I wished I wished my fucking
likes were more normal.
A lot of people want to be fucking
weird and out there. I want to,
I wish people liked the fucking my,
I wish I could play three songs on my
iPod without saying someone saying,
what the fuck is this?
That's the theme to welcome back Kotter.
It's on my fucking eye part.
It makes me happy.
I've got some stupid shit on my iPod to,
it's the greatest American hero.
I'm walking it all day.
Wow.
Imagine trying to put that show on today.
They were like,
what the fuck is going
on to my next an Afro?
That skinny dude with the Afro
was just beating everybody's ass.
Beat anybody up on that show. Of course
he did. Where did he get his power from?
Greatest American hero. Where'd he
get his power from? I don't remember.
Running into walls a lot.
Fucking glory holes
as skinny 80s fucking
blonde guy in tights.
He was my first celebrity sighting when
I moved to Los Angeles at a glory hole.
No Starbucks.
Basically the same thing.
I used to sell coke to have drove
Loreal greatest American hero.
He used to go there and play the greatest
American hero and he was just suck my
Dick Print April.
I swear you're not going to believe
who they going to believe the greatest
American hero. Come on dog. Who
Do you think you'd deal with?
It's just a fun dude and
you hit another one man.
You're just a chain smoking motherfucker.
I know in my fucking head this is,
this is a nighttime radio like it's cool.
It's cool that we can smoke in here.
I mean I don't smoke,
but I liked the fact that
you can't smoke in here.
There's not a radio station in the
world where you can actually smoke in a
studio. That's done, man.
Those are businesses,
man does not a places of art.
Every time you go to do you have like
friends that do radio like Dale Dudley and
radio. It's like Arizona
for six and a half years.
Never done Tucson radio.
Somehow they like Tucson's
against entertainment. Really?
Why the shittiest fucking comedy club in
the world that still exists since 1982
song from you? 90 minutes.
That's where I fly out of,
but it's 90 minutes with
no fucking traffic lights.
It's just desert and a border check.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Border Patrol has a 50 mile radius.
How did this fucking town,
you're like only a couple miles
from Mexico. How'd this town evolve?
Cause it's like a line but
it's sort of an art town.
The copper mine went bust in the 70s so
all the property values dropped and all
the fucking hippies swarmed
in. But really? Yeah,
they occupied Bisbee cause there
was selling property. There's no,
no work altogether though.
That always freaks me out.
Like how to gain neighborhoods start.
How did you know, how does everybody say,
listen, this fucking two of us
were living in this one building.
The building next door has got, yeah,
same way. Burning man started, right?
Yeah. Hey, this is cool. You stopped
doing your yearly thing to yeah,
because too many people showed up.
I didn't know the whole point of art.
We had a fucking death valley
party that we do every year.
Just like all the people you meet on the
road every year in Atlanta and you know,
two people there, they're
fucking great, but you're on the,
they're not your friends cause right.
So the whole idea
was to bring all those people into
death valley with no fucking cell phone
reception or TVs and it
was as little motel. Uh,
and we did that for till I get
to a point where seven years in,
well, the people that brought people last
time brought people and these people,
so none of your friends are
there and all their friends.
So it's like after a show
and you're just like shaking,
it could be cops and the cops
were around. Yeah, there. Yeah.
The house would tilt us to when
there was some plain clothes. Yeah.
I would imagine that that you and your,
your crowd would be a perfect dark valley.
Seven cops in death valley.
So the one guy comes in a polo shirt
and they're like, he's a cop. The only,
we're the only ones that don't know
where tourists. That's hilarious. Yeah.
Polo shirt.
Sir.
Can I w I permission to wear a shirt
with no collar to permission denied.
You don't have to you.
You're a bad undercover officer.
If you needed a t shirt to convince
a fucking perp, come on boy.
Get out there.
Put them in pink underwear.
There's your boy, right sheriff,
our pile. He's the guy in Arizona.
He's amazing. He's on my list. Yeah. Nice.
I haven't like, I had to pick one
comic, so I went with Ralphie May.
I knew it was going to be a fat black guy.
He had a pulmonary. Listen, how close
had been a black comedian anymore.
Really southern. It's more and more
southern. Does he doing Fargo now?
He just, he just switched
it up a little bit. Ralph.
He's just getting out of the
hospital, you know? Yeah.
He had a whole battery embolism
and there's part of me going,
he's so many points at my death pool.
Oh, I'm doing good. And I'm like, oh,
that's my friend.
But if he lives or dies,
it's not stop my control.
I had to pick one comic and I had a who
did you just mentioned that was on my
death pool. Oh, Joe Arpaio.
That's my wishlist. Oh,
add one pig. That was a wishlist, which
was Nancy grace. Nancy grace. Now, um,
now Joe Arpaio,
this all these weird border guys,
man,
that's a weird way to live,
man. You're living as the law enforcement
and a place that's known to have people
sneaking in from a third world country.
That's where things get crafty. You know,
things get real tricky when you're
dealing with that sort of a situation.
He got a bunch of people sneaking
into your state all the time. I mean,
it's probably a reason why he's more,
more fucked up than anybody else.
And I want to, he's in Phoenix. No, he's a
fucking Egomania. Oh, he's nuts for sure.
But I mean that attitude is acceptable
somehow or another more down there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like right next to the chaos.
But it's easy to make an us and
them situation out of that. Sure.
But people really want to stop that
nonsense mean they want to stop Mexico
from coming in Arizona.
And one of the reasons why Arizona is
so like Republican and so you know,
so right wing is because they're right
next to fucking Mexico. You know,
I think that's the same way Texas is,
you know,
and the same way southern California,
San Diego is really conservative to
you actually on a much smaller level.
They fucking hate Canadians at
the border to do. They really,
cause they don't tip.
Oh what are the fucking tipping is
one of the most important things.
I have no fucking work
the UK all the time.
And they're assholes as you fucking can.
I get ketchup.
Like normally this comes with ketchup
where I'm from and I don't want to put you
out, but can you get, and they've,
they're fucking cunts cause they,
cause they don't work for tips. Yeah.
Yeah. We're giving tips. It's big.
It's a good system. It's good. It's good
to be real generous. Tommy Lee Jones,
you just started getting some Tommy Lee
Jones with the new lighting. Really?
That's my new look, Tommy. Well, at
least you're going with good people.
You know know the gay guy from no,
the horrible old Tommy Lee Jones.
Oh, the old covenant. That's sad.
Sad, Bro. You end of this podcast
on a big downer note. We'd done. No,
we're not done.
I'm just going.
I gotta pee so I'm trying to think of
when to end this. Just go peace out.
Who's on your shorts back? Christine
Levine. Christine Levine. Wicked funny.
Cool. She should be the new Roseanne,
but really no one will notice.
Really awesome. Willing to charge
it out. Talked to Brian for it.
I'm going to pee and then
we'll wrap it up with chuck.
Let's talk behind his back.
All right,
let's do it like how we used to Doug
and he really doesn't like women though.
I know he hates it when
you say you hate women.
That's what it used to be. Right? Like
he, he was really concerned about like,
people are like, you're a woman
hater in it and drove him crazy.
And like when people say that to them or
something like that, remember that? Yeah.
Yeah. No, he was a, I don't know if
he's still is like that, but yeah,
he's so mellow now.
I've seen him fucking just dress
down a chick for no reasonable,
some dumb chick. But that's what comics
thrive on. Still putting. We're not you.
We need a dumb chick. Stop yelling
at her for being dumb. She's dumb.
She's here because she's dumb.
My favorite,
my favorite part though
earlier was when you,
you call Joe Joey Diaz on that change
art. And he was like, what's a change jar?
And I'm like thinking like,
how do you not know how you fix it?
I swear it was Joey Diaz.
He fucking stole my change jar because
everyone would come in and out.
But only Joey was denying
that he was doing drugs.
So anytime someone's denying what
they are known for defensively,
yeah. When's your next break? Cause you
usually never stole from you going Ah,
coked out of my brain and then just stole
your shit, right? No, I'm trying to,
I'm trying to working out.
I'm trying to work it out and I'll
just borrow your VCR. My girlfriend
is really is addicted to flash dance.
I can't believe they remade that movie.
Did are you taking a break soon?
Because I know you do like
stand up for like six months.
You're on the road or something like
that and then you take breaks or
yeah. Yeah. I always say I'm quitting.
I don't know.
Who knows?
I've UK dates booked after
that. I'm not bogus. Shit.
You got in trouble last time you were
overseas, right? Like I remember seeing,
I remember seeing there was some,
like you said,
they are so easy to fucking
stir up fake fucking
the newspapers is so bored.
They have like 19 newspapers on an island.
Right. Then it got some guy get
in trouble though or like some DJ
censored or something because he just
mentioned a youtube clip of mine.
Yeah.
What happened?
I was doing the BBC at sub
fucking poor bastard afternoon,
like BBC snotty radio.
They treat their radio like fucking
Winston Churchill still fucking talking on
it. And this guy isn't it? I did
a perfectly straight into, yeah,
we're performing here for
however long and blah, blah blah.
And he goes, but you're a very
controversial, and I go, yeah,
well there's not none of that I can do.
So he just mentions if you don't
believe it's not for everybody,
if you don't believe it, see as Youtube
clip about Sarah Pailin and the old no,
not to. It's not. So people
actually went there. It's about,
it's just a dumb retard baby.
It's a really funny bit.
How's it go? I don't know.
It's fucking railing on. Just
Sarah Pailin. Evan a retard baby.
And how she didn't use it in the
debates and I don't know, I never, I,
I went back because the fucking guy,
it was almost fired from BBC for
mentioning that Youtube Clip.
He was being insensitive to fucking
retards or whatever they call them over
there wasn't your bit something
like she had a, what was it?
She had two sons.
Okay.
And they were both retarded.
How did it go? Yeah,
one was at Down's syndrome
and the other was a
oh, uh, uh,
elected to go to Iraq
or something like that.
I never watched him fucking clip until
it came up when he said it and I watched
a clip. I go, fuck. That was a funny bit.
He used to put so much
more effort into comedy.
Do you do,
when you write,
do you like just think of ideas and like
remember them or do you take notes at
all or because you're constantly
coming at me, shit on my hand,
like my fucking attention span
and my memory is such shit. Now
you write them on your hand. I'll write
it on my hand until I get to a notebook.
I don't carry a fucking notebook. Do you?
If you have one of those droid phones,
you can actually die. I know, I
knew you were going to do this it
and then your bits will
be on Google's offices.
I'm in first class,
first class and I out my old fucking
fucking dog yeared notebook to take notes.
And I go to the first class.
Um,
does anyone have a pen?
And I wanted to work on
my set on the way here.
No one had a pen. Everyone had a
fucking, I'll text you at Bra. Yeah.
No, I'll just type it in the
air. A lot of drawing anymore.
I wonder what the fuck's going to happen
to cursive. It's that going to go.
It's going to grow. I could not
write in cursive right now. Yeah.
It's going to go writing itself. When
I have to write any guy, fuck it.
Send something and fill out an
actual piece of paper. I'm like, wow,
this is an alien thing. Making
a little mark. I have to,
I hope you recognize my mark.
I fucking Accountant Harvey
Altman Ma mentioned to buy
a fucking seven hours ago.
Yeah. Can you just take
that out on my account or
something? You're my accountant.
Why do I have to write a check?
He's one of the fucking guys I
have to sit and write a check to,
which is so forth.
He doesn't want the ability to just take
money out of your county, Michael Wacky.
It's, we need bit coons.
Careful, bro. Bitcoin's Bro.
That's the internet currency.
Right. Well that leads us to our
next episode about fear factor too,
right?
Coming up on bankruptcy.
What do you think about this whole
bitcoin thing about the idea of a, I mean,
what is the concept of it is
it's a monetary form of currency.
It's on the Internet. Right? And
people agreed to it. How does it work?
What's it back by [inaudible]
carrots. Stupid. Yeah,
but it's kind of interesting.
Not far, not even an hour. Um,
it's interesting because, um,
our, no, it was pretty close.
Um, because um, uh, the,
the bitcoins is like the first attempt
I've ever heard anybody coming up with
some sort of a currency. Even if it's
like really minor league. I mean,
remember what Napster was
like when it first came out.
That was pretty minor league. Look
what Napster became, you know,
all these years later, look at, you know,
you're getting songs
instantly on your phone.
That shizam thing where it's hooked up.
It tells you what the song is.
You play it, you press Shizam. There's
music playing you pressure exam.
It records a song real quick for
like 15 seconds, sends it somewhere.
It sends it back to you,
tells you what the song is,
then gives you an option to buy it. It's
all right there on your fucking fallen.
I mean, that's, that's insane.
I mean that there's never been anything
even remotely like that before, you know?
Yeah.
I can text.
He's like Joey Diaz from
five to two years ago,
but I'm not angry about it. I like
what you find yourself railing against.
What's new is when you're old, that's
when you're your fucking grandparents.
They all right. I just, I, I don't
have the fucking, I don't need it.
Like if I have a need to do all that
thing with a fucking cell phone, I don't,
I have no,
my life is really easy.
I've had a really good life
and I have no problems.
I don't need to fuck. I live in a place
I don't need to map quest anything.
Like it's over there.
I almost wish I wanted more.
Really?
That's interesting.
So what do you get your kicks out of?
That was kind of the whole
point of the DMT trip,
which is unexplainable with you,
was about your desire and desire is
almost an anti Buddhist thing. But
yeah, I don't, I wish, I
wish I wanted more. Hmm.
Fucking Louis C K said,
oh yeah.
I think he's a something I read
about myself after the Louis C K
that was awesome. By the way, Doug,
that was really weird to watch because,
and I know you, but it was also, I
thought you did amazing in it. All right.
My favorite episode,
I almost felt like I pause to shill
for applause and gave it to me.
No a fuck. Now I don't remember
my point. You're Louis C K
we're talking about having joy.
Take a joy.
You wish you had more joy in what
you do. Yeah. No fucking yes.
I lost the point. Um, what, what
do you get your kick out of?
Do you get your kick out of performing?
Do you get, you've got to killing still.
Do you still enjoy like a
fun set? No. No. Wow. Well,
I know I'm always relieved that I
didn't have a shitty set at best.
Like is this psychological? I don't
know everything psychological. Right.
But I'm saying is this like something
that's changed in life and just the way
you've done, but I can't pinpoint
it because I'm a logical person.
Like I can really, I don't want to
have to go to a fucking guy to talk.
Like I try to find,
that's why I'm not listening to your
boring fucking bar conversation because in
my head, yeah, I'm boiling something down
to a point in your head, your your work.
My background can't find where
I became kind of miserable. Hmm.
I know it somewhere around the breakup
with my wife but not connected like I was
kind of like in a manic phase anyway.
Well it's also could be the fact that
you're drinking a lot of alcohol on a
regular basis and that just really is
going to depress you and a certain extent,
it's not eliminated from the fucking
list of suspects. I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm really kind of tweaking
about this coffee thing.
It's very shocking to me how much
different I feel from not doing coffee for
eight days. You know? I really
didn't think it was going
to be that big of a deal,
but the, the, the big deal
is, and I'm not tired anymore.
I used to get tired in the
day, like somewhere in the
day I'd get tired, you know,
late afternoon or something.
And then I just have to force
myself to go to the gym.
So I'd have another cup of coffee and
then I'd fire up, then I'd go work out.
But I was tired when I got there. I'm
not tired anymore. I like the whole day.
It's like even, and I was like, oh,
this is what you're supposed to be like.
He's supposed to be even, you're not
supposed to be just fucking spiking every,
you know,
fucking hour and a half with some dark
liquid that fires up your fucking adrenal
glands.
Gray. I'm about to phone
it in. Come on baby.
You're not phoning it in Tuck.
I love,
let me get you on fucking Kale
shakes this point. I love Bingo.
Do you think maybe it's something
to do with relationship wise?
Cause say you don't have sex anymore.
I mean what do you need to show?
What the fuck's going on here?
What's this love line here,
Brian?
It's been since I've been a
fucking adult in any relationship.
The more the more you
like them as a person,
unless I want to fuck them.
Maybe your overall
good Dick. I'm saying good
Dick. I don't know man.
You think if you say laying
confidence doesn't mean she cared.
It'd be you're hanging
out with the wrong crowd.
Maybe not hanging out with a positive
crowd. We need to move to la.
You might not have to move back or
to podcast comics. Sell fucking bag.
Come hang on us. You can let
her know. You can live here.
We'd be here all the time.
All you have to do is come
back here and we could do this.
We could fuck around like this all the
time and we do shows and has to leave
five foot. No you don't.
You don't have to live here.
You can live in fucking Crestline man.
You could live in the god Damn Mountain.
You can live in Pasadena. So town, it
was a town Crestline and the mountains.
Lake Arrowhead up in the mountains.
You don't, you don't have to live here.
You could live. There's a lot of spots
outside. No, no. I like small town.
I mean you can find small town like
knowing everyone's name at Safeway.
I hear Ya. Hey, you love it then that's
good. But you could also have resume.
Should have got that small. Maybe go
do a residency, bro. You don't have a,
would you have a dog to bring
them? Fuck it. Fuck no residency.
Wrong to a dog. Kind of talk back.
Speaking of the fucking Tucson,
please help me. Oh, okay. When is it
the reality though? December 10th.
December 10th ladies and gentlemen get
on it. Where can they buy these tickets?
It's Walsh, Brody Stevens, Brendan
Walsh, Brody Stevens at the fucking one,
three ups. Oh Jesus. Folks, we've got
music in the mix. Well, Neil Hamburg,
come on son. Never seen his act.
Heard good things. Who else? Uh,
Garret stab as a local
and of course a beautiful,
fantastic guests that from Ms.
Lynn Shah, Croft Shazamm. They go,
so that's a fucking hell of a show,
ladies and gentlemen.
Hell of a show December 10th get on that
Shit. And they can buy tickets where?
I don't know. Somewhere you can find
it here it out. You're not stupid.
December 10th juice did,
but then I couldn't. Tucson,
Arizona, the Rialto theater.
Doug Benson and posse and crew.
You're, you're having fun, dude. Look,
you need to surround yourself with more
positive people. This is hurting me.
Hanging out with you here,
hearing you all bummed out.
It's about really bummed out.
I'm just really fucking new at being.
I haven't gotten high in a fucking year.
Like is that what it is?
But you're being Debbie Downer a
little bit. I'm always a little bit,
he just, well, I mean,
you're not having sex to me.
Hyper aware of everything other than
it's not a tripping is never good for
fucking entertainment. No,
it is. It is. It was just,
I tried a small fucking porch and it's
still good. It's still good. It was fun.
Those are fun. It's a fun
conversation. It's cool.
People enjoy these conversations.
They get to see you.
You know who you really are,
man.
They get to see all of us who we
really are and all sorts of different
situations with tripping.
So more feedback about
the first one where I go,
I that had to be boring to everyone.
It was just me talking to you
about old days and she was fun.
People loved it.
But yeah,
you gotta think you have
a tendency to go negative.
It's a tendency and you're thinking
to go negative and it unfortunately,
it fucking sets little triggers
in your brain and you know,
it sort of defines your outlook on
things when you do that and you can,
you can fuck yourself in bad state of
mind. We can forgive fear factor too.
But if you start going
motivational speaker, Tony Robbins,
I'm going to get one of those Bobbi Brown
headsets. I don't want to go out there.
I'm going to show to people fives.
And you know what? The negative vibes,
creating negative atoms in your DNA,
you make negative children. You don't
want that in residence is all off man.
He needed a different crystal on your
neck. She'd be excited. Be Be excited.
Be.
That was the,
we could go off forever
about motivational speakers.
But the last thing I want to talk
to you about his comedy classes,
cause I thought this is really funny
how while cs I've talked to on the phone
again, it's like Dane Cook,
like I talked to Kyle, she's,
I go, it was, it was funny. It
created good Internet buzz. Yeah.
It's a dumb thing.
I'm always,
I don't have to be high to be hyper
aware of how pointless comedy is and the
fucking scam that we get away with doing
this for a living when it should be
free. You say that and I
agree and in a certain way,
but in another way I don't agree because
I was always happy to pay for it and I
enjoy it still as an art form. I think
it's the most fun form of entertainment.
I think that we've been in it for so
long, you know, I think for some of us,
we might've forgotten how much we
appreciated it in the beginning, you know,
forgotten. It's still the same thing.
I've always forget. I was always,
you're always hating it from
the beginning. No, not from
the beginning. 10 years.
I knew the Hollywood blow job
was like all this fallacy.
I don't want to do anything more.
Say hedbergs joke about, Oh,
you're a comic.
Can you write or can
you act as was saying,
oh, you're a, you're a, you're a cook.
Can you farm?
Yeah.
I remember. Thank you for
letting me fucking embarrassed.
Mitch Hedberg is fucking grave.
He got through it though.
You still got a good punch line out
of it because there was a pause. This,
you know, it's to be, if you
didn't, you didn't do a lot of,
I saw I've only had three drinks
by the way, in fucking three hours,
so not everything's great.
No worries. No, I'm just,
I'm worried about prayer.
You're fine. I can't wait.
21 years of comedy. Do you know how
many times I've played the Bray Improv?
Never really.
So if it goes poorly,
I'm not worried about my career.
Do
it. It's a great comedy
club. Oh No, I love it.
I'm just praying this prayer is one of
the things we'd go in with that attitude
of it doesn't fucking matter.
You're usually funnier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
And I'm looking forward to show
tonight, man. No pressure. No pressure.
I'm just going to sit and be creepy in
the back and if you're doing something I
don't like,
I'm just gonna shake my head.
Put myself at like a really nice position
last night. Yeah, last night. Uh, I go,
yeah. Rogan said he's coming, but he's
no way he's coming. Why is he sad?
Because it's fucking Irvine
plastic. Yeah, no fucking way.
We already worked it out
that it was coming tonight.
Yeah. Well No. You said, Oh,
I'm going to come to both and I know
you're not going to come to both.
Who would say that? It's
high. It's ridiculous.
Why would you,
why would I?
That would be even creepier if I just
sit and watch the same James Robbins,
a man of his word. I go, no, he
stated flipping leaves and there's no,
there's no glass to the comedy.
Love you dad. There's no one joke,
no dead fucking Patrice O'Neal wrapped
up in a Greg Geraldo with a Freddy Soto
on top.
There's no comedy worth
driving to Irvine from La.
That's not true.
I was going to go see you if
you didn't do the podcast.
I know you were only doing Irvana
would've gone to see you there for sure.
Cause brand to me is almost
a convoy of right now.
If you drive to the fucking Irvine,
they make traffic move as a
convoy with flags on Towncars.
Oh,
I wish that'd be awesome.
Could just have magic. I go,
Hey, I'll do your podcast. Uh,
I think we can con my record company in
a getting a driver and he Rogan goes,
ah, now I have my own service. I'll have
him pick you up at one 30. Good for you.
Because that odd, no, but the,
the fact that you have a bell that
you ring out on your porch too,
to summon the person. That's good.
No, no, that's affluence. But no,
that you're not someone I
feel uncomfortable around
like you and Ron White where
the two guys that I all right.
No matter how you're still,
you feel like you've changed. Who have
you ever met that the got some money,
you know, for a lot of people,
you know what it is man.
They get something and then they don't
want to lose it and then they get scared
and then they clam up and then they stop
doing anything. Controversial styles.
I know like a tell, I've never,
no one gets close to a towel.
Like he's just, well he's, you know what,
I don't like to ever judge anybody
or look at them all in categories.
I just tell you who I love
and I love it. Tell, tell,
I would say is fucking pound for pound
as they say in your industry. The best,
the best of our generation.
Um,
I don't know if I can agree with that
because you know, quite honestly,
I shift back and forth on a bunch of
different guys. I go back and forth,
but I stopped trying to put them
in an order, but it Hedberg guide.
But like the joke for joke,
no one has more fucking
jokes and personality than
a tell five jokes in a job.
I will never, you know, argue with you
on that. I just think he's amazing,
but I don't, I don't put them all
in an order, you know? I just have,
I've decided somewhere along the line
just to appreciate him. Don't try this.
A little trap for me at least. [inaudible]
Thompson part of it where you go,
would you want to be that miserable of
a fucking person to be that good to be
that funny? You think you're doing it?
He's one of us really knew by how much,
but yeah, no, he's really
like, he makes me like, I,
I go just, let's go to Costa Rica
together. Let's just go on vacation.
But I got to this pilot and I just know
it's no good and I'm didn't find he had
a DVD like for three years he's been
editing, but he hates every word of it.
You're like,
great.
More fucking jokes in a
conversation while I'm drunk.
Then I write in a fucking notebook
book in a year. Well he would,
he is as a real fucking professional.
It's a boot Koski thing.
You want to be that fucking miserable
of a person to put out that good art.
Me,
I'd rather fucking phone it in.
I honestly don't think it's an either or.
I think you can just enjoy the whole
process. I fun. I love it. Hey,
faggot is about to email and
say this thing went on too long.
We have two minutes.
Pause and then uh, yeah,
hard for us right now because the,
we're running out of space on the
iTunes. I want fried clams. Listen,
you dirty bitches, you know we
love you. Send our love sitting.
I love throughout the world.
Send our love to the
fleshlight for sponsoring this
podcast. Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and entering the code name, Rogan,
and you get 50% 15% off and you will
use the same masturbation device that me
and Brian do. Mince. Yummy. I like it.
I know I'd have used it to, but last
time I did your fucking podcast team,
you kind of flashed it around
like I didn't give a tag
and you didn't give it to,
I forgot. That's still just
a space. I apologize. Great.
Still have your fucking Nike sneakers.
I stole from me on the map.
I'll have the plush light send
them to you. How about that?
Two 12 van Dyke.
Don't do it.
Why I don't do it on this one.
You guys send Shit but
address it to Bingo.
Just send whatever weird shit. She
loves it. She loves nothing but mail.
We live in a town.
My mail still means south.
They go fuck yourself from
me and Joe Rogan on it.
Band and Joey.
Oh and then I t.com checkout
the Alpha brain balance.
New Tropic supplement.
Checkout,
new mood to five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement and shroom tech.
The quarter subs, mushroom
energy supplement, which is
fantastic for working out.
Check out all that shit. Go to
Joe rogan.net. Click on that link.
Enter in the code and
get yourself 10% off of that too.
All right. Thank you Doug. Stan,
hope it was a beautiful,
as always,
can't wait for your show tonight.
Thank you, Brian. Red Band.
Thank you all you fucking freaks.
We got Shane Smith from vice.com next
week we're going to talk to this mother
fucker about the craziest Shit on
earth. He's just getting back here. Oh,
that guys.
He's one of my fucking heroes too.
That guy's getting back from Japan right
now. He's checking out the reactors.
Okay. He just got back from India. We
hadn't seen a toilet and a month. Yeah,
that was a savage one guy of why doesn't
everyone know this? Yeah, exactly. Well,
I think that's going to change soon.
It's a jack and he's awesome.
He's awesome and he's going to be
here next Tuesday. You fucking freaks.
All right. We love you. Take
care. Bye Bye everybody.
Okay.